i'm i'm live now and i tweet it too
guys did you hear that she's live now yeah that's the intro
of going live now i'm going live i'm going in i'm going in
live but not alive i'm alive and i'm live let's see you are
not alive
joy i was like i can call now and then i was like hey and
then she was like no you didn't even say anything i was just
like oh no i did i was like hey and then you were like wait
i think i did change something at this grid and i was like
no that's just me i'm i can't hear you oh are you muted
what's what's happening and then i was like oh wait give me
a so wait give me a sec My coffee's coming.
I'll be right back.
I have no reception in this room.
Give me a sec.
Wait, did you get your coffee?
Huh?
Wait.
Wait, wait.
I thought she got her coffee.
Wait, is she just now getting her coffee?
Welcome to Fears of Fathom.
I don't know if Doki's ever played any of these games
before.
I'm back.
Hi.
Sorry, I had to...
But they have to like call my phone to let in, but I have no
risk.
My reception in this room is so fucking bad.
I have to get out of the room to accept the call.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
So basically when I was not alive when I first took, when I
called Mint, she thought it was discreet, but I was, I was
not okay.
It was just me.
I was not okay.
korea it was fun it was fun i did i guys it it i you can't
get anything out of mint because like i told her i was like
i can't say anything she said nothing to me for real yeah
yeah yeah she was like what are you doing korea and i was
like i can't say anything or they're gonna get me
yeah because i was going to the ace combat thing yeah and
then i asked her what she was doing and she's like oh you're
gonna have to wait next week i was like oh no they're gonna
get her too i was yeah we had our secret we had our little
secrets yeah um but i'm i'm just so up right now uh like i
came back i didn't like the thing is like i came back
usually you need like several days to acclimate back to your
back to your time zone yeah like i I, like I, when I came
back, I went instantly to sleep and it was already like
nighttime.
So then I was like, it should be fine.
I think I fixed it.
Like it should be fine, usually no, right?
No, no, it was not.
And then the day two, and then day two, I couldn't sleep.
Like even though I like had a, like the, like I slept at an
NA time, when at the moment I came back on day two, I
literally went to sleep at nine a.m.
because I couldn't sleep at all.
And then, and then it like, and then yesterday I tried it
again I got it back I it was like 9 a.m.
the next two days and then yesterday I got it back again and
then and then I'm so fucking tired I am so tired right now
um and so bad it's so bad and I thought I I I thought and I
went straight back to work too so it was just like my body
is like self-destructing right now you know what it sounds
like you're no no no no no that can't be that that can't be
i hope i hope uh since you're moving right since you're
moving i hope they approve your visa the moment you move
yeah that would be really funny wouldn't it in the japan on
the day that i move yeah i hope the moment you know you find
you unpack everything everything has been unpacked and then
you get the email i hope you can't curse me with that
because i've already thought about it it's okay i'm double
i'm i'm doubling it i'm doubling it and giving it to the
next person
last i heard i did say it might get approved at the end of
june and um that's when all my stuff arrives i hope it's
like beginning of july because then at that time you'd be
unpacking all the stuff that arrives yeah because i'd be
like wow my new cafe is so great yay and then you gotta do
it i don't know i don't think i'll do it though i think i've
tried to move to japan i've like back in 2020 i got a job in
japan and then i remember that yeah yeah and i was gonna go
and and then they ghosted me and then i got another job yeah
and they said oh yeah we'll give you a visa for japan and
then they only started doing that after i left you're above
me too Yeah, because you were like, what's the update?
And it wasn't even for you, too.
Yeah, because you were asking for it.
And then when they finally started the process, it wasn't
even for you.
No?
I remember too, because I was just like, oh, I got this
other job in Japan.
I could go for it.
But I, because I really want to move over there.
So would you be able to do that?
because i'm i'm turning down another job for your job yeah
they were like yeah we could do that yeah and then like and
then and then you waited and then you're like hey remember
then i asked about that visa thing and then they're like oh
yeah we're trying to work on it and then and then you find
out it wasn't even for you i know yeah and now it's for
everybody else yeah
It's okay.
And now you can't, it's okay.
Your piece is going to get approved.
The moment you unpack, I feel it.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Doki.
You're my good luck, child.
I hope it happens the exact moment you put down the last
item too.
Oh, yeah.
I check.
I'm like, oh, I got an email.
The monkey paw girl.
I'm the dokey the dokey pot girl I'm imagining you're
underneath your glove it's like all shriveled yeah I was
shriveled I was like
disgustingly curls and then like even when you use up all
the fingers it just resets itself it doesn't mean oh that's
weird what happens when you use up the monkey pot it's just
it ends like it like you it's like you use up all the wishes
basically until all the paws are curled up but mine just
resets yeah i just open it yours is like yours goes like hey
high five then it starts all over yeah it's like it's like
don't leave me
no it's like because like it's uh open palm first and then
when it fully curls it's like hey bro bro and then when you
fist it you're like yeah the high five down low down it goes
it goes bro fist and like when you know how like people like
pull up yeah it just opens up
all right anyway this is a gaming stream this is oh yeah
yeah um I'm chibi.
I'm a dokey chibi right now because I want to feel included
because yeah, I'm chibi because for some reason when I click
into the game, it starts making me lag a little bit.
Yeah.
I'm on my potato PC because I'm moving.
And then I didn't want to feel left out.
So I was like, hey, I want to be a chibi too.
Also, because she didn't want to join my collab room because
she's a fucking pussy.
Okay, I gave him 35 extra money.
This is how I repay you.
I hope you grow old.
I'll stop it before it happens.
Is that a threat?
I hope you grow old.
Oh, no.
I'm young and beautiful forever.
No matter what, you'll always be older than me.
Wow, you literally passed my age probably.
No, I know.
I know.
No matter what.
You don't know anything.
I know.
You know nothing, Donkey Bird.
You know nothing.
What the fuck do you mean?
Whenever you and Matara stream together, you have like the
wavelengths that you're sending each other.
Okay, do not put me on the same level.
She's way beyond.
You two send each other, you're like, oh, you know, like,
like same hat, same hat.
You see, the moment you two are together, you're like, same
hag, same hag.
This is offensive.
Do not put me on the same level.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'm getting my coffee.
I'll be right back.
I don't think you need it.
Why did I ask Doki to play this with me?
Remember Doki has graying hair.
I know.
I've seen it.
I've seen the gray strands in her hair.
Yeah.
You know what?
Some of my chat.
Hag to hag communication.
okay yeah that's why you've been getting along with matara
so well recently too huh no i'm like i'm like her approach
i'm like an apprentice
we don't need more than one of her but like i'm like the
apprentice she's teaching me the ways of what to make her to
make her feel young again you know oh i'm taking her like
six seven yeah
teaching her like how the zoomers speak and then she's
teaching me hag speak so i can communicate with you better
what have you learned what have you learned okay use your
teaching it's time to go what i learned i became more
alcoholic in korea that's for sure
that's what i learned power of soju all right shall we yeah
shall we shall play now what is this game i i have no idea
have you ever played a fears to file them before okay no
they're like they're like people like send in their true
stories asterisk and they make a video game out of them with
artistic liberties it's like they took some stories off of
reddit and then it's yeah see at the bottom it says you have
a story send it but this is their first multiplayer one a
story over we should we should write something on stream and
then send it over we should my name is mint phantom yeah we
could be in the game he would have to make models i know we
could be like i'm haunted by a very annoying ghost very old
this is the hack to get into the game i think oh gosh i'm
really starting to lag what's wrong oh no only when i click
out of that click into the game i start lagging this is
based on a true story it is right now this is the story this
is the story if i click connect okay i'm gonna invite you i
haven't booted the game up oh my god oh it says it's only
about two hours like oh we can finish i think i'm gonna be
up packing until like oh i am again i had because it's like
you're literally moving your uh everything yeah i've been up
until like 4 a.m every night holy that's crazy see all right
let's see okay or the dev literally says you are playing the
first episode but i'm too tired to make another multiplayer
what all right i'm waiting for my friend to join is i don't
think she's gonna join guys is it i like how these just
settings are graphics it's like nasa nasa computer and then
toaster and then not toaster you did you make sure i'm on
toaster okay i'm on toaster i just gotta be sure you know i
just got you know just in case i run toaster pc all right
let me oh yeah yeah can you actually teach me stuff on steam
sure so what you need to do is you go to friends and chat
and then you click on my name and then i already invited you
did you know get it no because you did not do it correctly i
did okay i'm i'm here now to help you all right i'm sending
invite invite for a survive oh invite invite friend invite
not there's no way i i there's no notification i've sent it
like five times i can watch you hundred times i'm gonna you
could watch me yeah wait it doesn't show up though i invited
can you see that me inviting you huh i invited you to watch
invite oh where did you go wait you disappeared you
disappeared on the friends list oh there you are you're back
in vtube studio oh my game just crashed oh yeah
i crashed your game i'm sending in the waves i'm sending in
why did you crash my game wait actually hold my computer
might be dying for real what how is it dying it won't let me
click on vtube studio that's fine i'm going back to open the
game yeah it's fine png just why are we not inviting each
other oh it crashed again wait what's happening oh what's
happening the moment i put up the game it's okay you're
hoarding all the bandwidth if you have the story yeah guys
she's moving over here that's where she's going she's
already here yeah to my to my one bedroom apartment don't
say that people think you can see that you're gonna sleep on
the floor that's right wait the game is actually crashing
though wait what's happening maybe at the reset you're i
like how when i booted the game your game started crashing i
know i've sitting on it for like an hour.
Wait, what the hell?
Do you have to...
I just keep booting up.
Mint Fantome is now playing Fears the Fathom Scratch Creek.
Oh, it opened.
It opened.
Alright.
Now send me the invite.
I'm doing it.
Oh, yeah, I can...
Oh, yeah, I got it this time.
Oh, yeah.
I'm booting it.
Yeah!
all right i'm i'm muting you i'm muting i'm mute i'm not i'm
lowering your thingy i'm lowering it i'm putting 154 here so
i remember because in case we get a call again we're like
why can't i hear her why yeah i put all right that's your
discord thing oh wait discord thing that's yeah that's like
you know how when you do the thing and then oh you put me at
like 154 yeah i put you at 154.
why am i so quiet all the time i don't know all right chat
how's i don't even know my sound gas alive i'm not alive my
audio team's not alive we're a mess so loud yeah i'm turning
it out okay got you done is audio team
but how do you worry but i think we're crunchy yeah are we
crunchy well it's immersive because yeah it's immersive it's
called immersion because we're we're in the vhs right now
okay i'm starting new game wait wait wait wait wait no wait
no oh you dang it you have to select it Ah, that's right.
Hurry up.
God.
Burk.
How do I...
You think you're so clever.
I do.
I can't.
I'm getting rid of chat.
I can't keep refreshing it.
Oh, my God.
Guys, if you want me...
Guys, if you want...
No, wait, what?
Like, it keeps freezing on your stream.
Oh, it's...
It did that when...
I think it did that one time.
But I think it's just because, like, was sort of low-key
dying no it it does it it like every stream for me multiple
times even on your actual pc yeah on my actual that's weird
yeah i only had that happen one time do you use browser like
obs for your chat no do you oh i do i think it's that i just
all i do is you know let's grab your youtube chat and i just
open it because it can open as its own window and i just do
that and to my third monitor wait no i mean like on your no
if you dream yeah when you go to your stream and then
there's you know there's the chat there you can just open it
to a new browser like a no i i have wait because you're
talking about the obs integrated chat right like i browser
source it and i copy the link oh you mean on your stream
it's dying i thought when you're talking about reading it
yourself um it has happened to me sometimes but i don't know
what's the cause for sometimes it's okay and sometimes i
have to refresh it uh i think it could be the code too
because youtube changed their coding i did i fucked up my
css yeah so i think like i think it could be a code that's
just like lagging it yeah all right i'm in
I'm being Marcus Reader.
Am I Marcus?
Wait.
Are you Marcus?
I'm Tessa.
Oh, you're me Tessa?
All right, I'll be Marcus.
I'll be Marcus.
I guess I'll die first, I guess.
Why?
It's always in the horror films.
It's like a trope.
Do you not know about the trope?
Wait, so I'm the sexy virgin girl that lives?
Yeah, yeah.
You want to be the sexy virgin girl that lives?
It's like cabin in the woods
All right Scratch Creek
April 30th Oh yeah she can't hear me I can't hear I can't
hear her She can't hear me Whoever is reading this Pardon my
writing ability
My girlfriend Tess Recently played your game We couldn't
help but notice a chilling scenario one of the episodes and
what happened to us.
Wow.
And Mint picked this game.
She persuaded me to write to you from my perspective as it
will increase the chances of the devs noticing this story.
I'll try to keep the information about our personal lives to
a minimum.
Back in our early days when we were living together, I had a
job offer, which I initially I'll have to turn down since it
required me to move to another state But test was adamant
that I accept the offer knowing how hard I had worked for it
She was ready to move out with me We did not have much
furniture Which meant it was a one-way drive with the
trailer Other survivors So real
Hello?
Oh shit Look at me I'm watering my plant Hello Hello
Where's...
Mint?
Is she still reading?
Alright.
I do feel like a dad in the 90s slash 80s.
There we go.
I guess I'll do all the gardening work.
Oh, there you are!
You know what this game showed me?
Hello?
Oh, all right.
Hey.
Shit finally looks like it's not from O3.
You know what?
It showed me that you're a very slow reader.
Let's knock out the heavy store.
Couch, TV, big boxes in the hall so we can balance the
weight of the trailer.
We'll toss in the lighter stuff last.
Sorry, I get into the mood.
We got two.
Yeah, you know, it says on my side, it's like, you're...
player two is still reading after i'm done yeah you're so
muffled oh i know washing the car took longer than i thought
why are they so muffled i know it's like it's not even a
wall it's a fence this fence is like muffling us i know oh
we're already behind here i'm gonna watch it tomorrow we
that ask him if that makes me wonder what i know what he's
going to say let me in
we own this house together i'm gonna throw my nose at you
oh my god i hope they get you i hope i hope the ghosts get
you How do I text my dad?
What is this?
Oh my god, I can hear you better in this angle.
You mean, if this door is...
Okay, I'm going to find the key.
I'm going from the garage.
Oh, wait, I can call my dad.
Also, Talon put a sway control morning, boy.
Today's the big day.
Yes, sir, we're packing up the last couple of boxes.
Also, if you're going to read your text, I'm going to read
my text, too, right next to you.
What time are you leaving?
Blair this evening?
Don't leave too late, you two.
I got Jacob at work.
Hey, Marcus, just checking in.
You still on schedule to move up this weekend?
Hey, Jay.
Yep, still on track and we're aiming to head out the 10th.
Let me know if you need anything on our end.
We'll do.
We're putting you in Studio B your first week.
Light session load, but you'll get a feel for the room.
You'll be mostly shadowing decks your first week.
It'll get you up to speed on our mastering stage.
systems i'm psyched dude what am i saying then work our way
to the back all right let's start with the couch wait how
are you here my audio gear oh okay you want me to read you
my text oh i got oh look at me mine okay i'm gonna read mine
okay i'm gonna drive is not that long what are you doing oh
you're calling boo will you be home late sorry boo i made
you pie wrapping this up and zooming you to my lady beef a
jerk why did i type why did i text you beef jerky did you
see that wait oh i still beef jerky yeah oh wait wait you
just yeah beef where am i i'm gonna move my i'm gonna move
myself so people can see the text i'll move myself too i'll
be give us a sec so we can have see our text guys guys i
have important text message that i have to answer Beep
jerky.
Beep jerky.
All right, let me move you two.
I need to hear the sound.
Will you be home late today?
Sorry, boo.
I made you pie.
Sad face.
Zoom into you, my lady.
You calling me your lady?
Damn!
You wanted to play this game.
This was a...
Wait, what's the cow?
I have zero cows per second.
Wait, is this like cookie?
Oh my god, it's cookie clicker.
Wait, what are you doing?
I'm getting cows.
We can't afford cows.
You don't see...
Oh, to be fair, back then houses were cheaper.
We can't text dad, my dad at work.
Hey, dad.
I have one cow per second.
Oh, I can't.
I can only...
I see it.
Wait.
What number are you at?
I see the game.
I'm at 167 cows now.
I'm at 1,000 cows.
I don't believe you.
Guys, she doesn't believe me.
I don't believe you because you're...
It means you're not spending your cows.
I 100% have.
You are not spending your cows.
I'm at...
I'm getting 44 cows per click.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Wait, there's more.
Oh, my God, there's more.
There's more cows?
Oh.
Oh, yeah, I have a farm.
I got found first.
Nope, we got it at the same time.
Nope.
I got it first before you did.
I'm about to get whatever the 9,000 thing is.
Oh, yeah, me too.
Hey, remember when they said this game is two hours?
I was just excited
Why would they say that?
Why would they lie to us about that?
Clearly this game is not just two hours What if the actual
gameplay is like 20 minutes And then everybody spends it on
A cow clicker A cow clicker I have 100 per clicker now I
have 200 per second Me too Um Um, me two times infinity.
Times infinity?
Yeah.
How many cows per click do you get?
Uh, I have, like, a thousand cows per click.
I have almost 3,000.
Um...
This is pathetic.
Um, I'm pumping my cows now.
I have almost 5,000.
That's a lie.
It's not a lie.
Actually, I almost have 9,000.
Oh My gosh.
I got the cow factory.
Holy hell.
Oh my gosh.
I'm swimming in cows.
Oh my god Oh, yeah, I can't stop moving.
I can't stop moving.
I can't stop moving I Can't stop moving holy cow.
There's holy cow.
There's so many cows Yeah Plus 5,000 per second I'm gonna
get to the 25 million.
Oh, I'm gonna get there first hmm Oh, wait, wait, there's 15
million.
Oh, my God, there's 30 million.
You could get 30 million points.
Yeah, it goes crazy.
It goes crazy.
All right.
I'm almost there.
Okay.
Increase.
More, more, more, more, more, more.
I'm going to get another cow factor just for safety.
I got the emperor clicker.
Oh, you got 2 million?
Yeah.
I'm about to reach it again.
Oh my god, that's so many cows.
That's so much power.
Wait, I don't have an auto-clicker on this.
Wait, can you just download it right now?
I guess I could if I wanted to.
I'm lazy.
You're 11k clicks per second?
How many factors do you have?
I have 47 clicks per second.
Or 47,000.
How many cows do you have per second?
I have 10,000.
What's what are you doing?
What you mean?
I'm clicking cows!
Alright, now I have emperor clicker.
Okay, good job.
I did it.
Keep going.
The rich only gets richer.
And you spend cows to make cows.
You're so right.
I'm up to spend.
Yeah, you have to spend cows and make cows exactly.
I wonder if I get to a hundred of them each.
I'm doing another emperor clicker.
Yeah, me too.
I have five of them.
Yep, five emperor clickers?
That's the strat said.
I have seven.
Now I have eight.
Oh my god!
She's un-cowable.
I love cow clicker!
unstoppable unstoppable they should have advertised this
honestly this should be its very own game you got the cow
pyramid you got the cow pyramid where are we in egypt right
now this is a different timeline where instead of cats it's
cows i'm making 245 000 cows per second oh my god
Oh, there's 30 million.
Wait, what's the top?
Holy, wait, do you actually see how far this goes?
How far does this go?
Oh my god, I don't even know what kind of number that is.
There's so many zeros.
What kind of number is that?
Is someone explaining what's happening?
It's called...
Did you think in the story, they're like, wow, we were about
to get killed.
We were...
We're playing our favorite...
We just had a competitive little cow clicking.
Yeah, we had a competitive cow clicking game that me and my
girlfriend will play all the time.
Oh wait, there's the pope clicker.
Yeah, I have one.
The pope is here.
Oh, just one.
The pope.
The pope is a cow.
Yeah.
Everything is cow.
You know, it's like lizard people, but it's cow people.
Yeah.
Think about that.
Actually, the cow people spread the lizard people meme.
Oh, so they won't know.
never know they would never guess cow yeah yeah it's like
propaganda like anti-propaganda against lizards yeah maybe
there's lizard people and cow people but they're like the
the cow people is like the illuminati for the lizard people
oh oh the lizard people think they're like oh my gosh don't
talk don't even get us started about the cow people oh
you're just like yeah and you're like oh you think we run
the government yeah the cow people are this run the secret
secret They run the secret government of the lizard people.
Wait, I'm about to get whatever's under Pope.
Oh, the 100,000?
Oh, I reached a heart.
Oh, I got an achievement for 100 million.
What'd you get?
The cow temple?
Oh, my God, I got it, too!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Look at all these cows.
A cow sphericy, yes.
They're always watching.
Cowspiracy.
That's why we have global warming.
Do you know, like, cows contribute to global warming because
they fart too much?
Yeah, they fart a lot.
Oh, the cows are so cute.
I can't be mad at them.
They can cause a little global warming as a tree.
Just a little bit, you know?
Yeah.
I wonder if there's PvP in this game.
I wonder if there's a leaderboard.
There's a leaderboard?
I wonder if there is.
They should add a leaderboard.
Wait, is the dev here?
Leave me at the top.
Dev, please.
Can you put a leaderboard?
Give us a cameo.
Yeah, me first and Doki Bird.
Yeah, no, no.
We'll send you a story.
Put us in.
I need more.
I need more cows.
I'm making almost a million cows per second.
A million cows?
I'm only 625,000 cows per second.
Are you feeding all these cows?
I'm an old McMinto had a farm.
Old Mimito at a farm.
E-y-y-y-y-y.
It's just cows, too.
There's nothing else.
This far she had many cows.
E-y-y-y-y-o.
And I'm moomoo here and I'm moomoo there and I'm moomoo
here.
And I'm moomoo.
Oh, my God, clicker.
I'm going to grab another cow tempo.
How many?
Wait, you only have one?
I have three right now.
oh dang i want more that's more than me actually yeah i need
more cows to get to a hundred and seventy five sometimes
gets creepy but it's we're just totally cowing it up yeah
this is the best zatsu game ever i know have you ever been
to a farm yeah have you no and there's i like i mean petting
zoos i don't think like that counts though uh no i've been
to a farm the real farms well i think i don't know you ever
seen a real cow there's like cow therapy there's cow therapy
yeah you like go and you cuddle with cows oh wait that's
cute i know i kind of want to do it i need therapy and cows
i wonder if it's i want to be cheaper than dog therapy you
know like during like exam season at universities you just
send in the dogs do that yeah yeah my school used to do that
it was like or i mean they still do during like it's like
exam week and then like finals week and then they have like
a special area uh where people like kids can cuddle the dogs
before they have a nervous breakdown over their exams in
future but you have to pay for it mine's for free and why
why would it be why would it be more expensive it's free No,
that's what I'm saying.
Do you think cow therapy is free or not?
Oh, I don't think so.
Therapy is not free.
You have to pay someone to listen to you.
We live in a society.
Do you see that video of the horse that goes around, plays a
piano to, like, kids in the hospital?
Yeah, he's so good.
I want his autograph.
Yeah, me too.
Joki's got a fever and the only prescription is more cow.
Cyber, think of this super channel.
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
Yeah.
I'm at God clicker now.
Yeah, I have five of them.
You have five of the God clicker?
Okay, now I have to get five of the God clicker.
The next one is a pretty big jump, though, so I haven't
gotten to the next one.
Oh, Rob, just adding more God clickers.
Me too.
Oh, man.
It's starting to get really big jumps from...
I'm so behind, well, she was playing this game on her in her
bathroom earlier while I was locked out of the house.
Like, of course she- I literally discovered it right in
front of you.
We were reading text.
What are you talking about?
Yeah, I was trying to read text from my dad because, uh, I
actually wanted to know if my dad's safe or not.
Wait, do you think it'll work in the background?
What do you mean?
Oh, my God, you just lagged there.
No, do you think it'll work?
Like, the, do you think the- The click will, the clicker
will work in the background?
The auto clicker?
Oh, wait, that's true.
Yeah, because I get a million dollars per second.
Try it right now.
Okay, hold on.
When 350, wait, how do I exit out of this?
Okay, 364, 355.
Okay.
I'm giving it a couple seconds.
We stopped at 365, guys.
365.
Oh, no!
It doesn't go in the background!
Oh, then we have to keep.
You have to stay!
You'll have, you know what would have been funny if you,
like, off your phone and it resets your progress.
I was waiting for that.
That's why I was like, you go first.
Okay.
No, I had trucks to my cows.
They would come back always.
Okay, I have nine God clickers now.
Me too.
Oh, yeah?
I have ten.
Me too.
Oh, yeah?
I have eleven.
Uh, one second.
Me too
She was buffering She was buffering It was processing the
request Yeah it was processing the request
Alright at 14 now How many cows per second do you make A
million cow A million, 25,400, and, uh, 29.
Only a million.
The rich only gets richer.
Someone should just eat the rich.
Eat the rich.
So then I can replace the rich.
Making the rich.
I'm almost surprised.
3 million cows per second.
Now I'm at 3 million cows per second.
Wait, that is more than 2 million.
Oh my, I just, it just processed in my head how many we have
to get for the next year.
I know.
Like, I need like 2 million from where I'm at.
It's crazy.
My finger hurts.
Coward.
Weak.
No, I'm still going.
I'm still going.
Why don't you take a little break, huh?
Why?
I'm happy at two times always.
Two times always.
Wait, I just hit the first.
I'm, I hit one billion.
Whatever that number is.
I can't.
It's too many.
It's too many numbers.
Oh, you just hit one.
Guys, it's not fierce to cow.
It's fierce to cow them.
Oh, are you almost at the two?
Yeah, I'm at almost at there.
oh my computer is breaking down there's too many kids taking
the cow with oh the cow power plant i got it oh i'm almost
there i didn't i didn't want to oh yeah you're just getting
you know you didn't want to be on the top for too long you
know you want to have an actual competition you're trying to
yeah but i'm still making three level up even the even up
the playing field
Wait, what's the power plant give you?
Um, it gives me, like, 10, 100,000.
For a second.
Oh, shit.
I got 16.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah?
I guess who just built her second power plant.
Dang, you're going fast.
Yeah.
It's like, I bet you, it's like, they're used to cow farts
to power it.
It's like, like, it's a special type of gas.
They learn to energize the farts.
Hold on, I'm gonna keep getting more.
Oh, oops.
That's fine.
I need to get another power plant, too.
I'm gonna, I've got some more god clickers.
I'm investing big.
Yeah, I'm about to.
I'm about to.
Yeah, me too.
I'm gonna get another one.
Methane power.
My methane power plant.
Methane 2.0.
I'm almost there.
Oh my god, the next step is 20 million.
Oh, 20 billion.
Yeah, it's kind of ridiculous.
I think we'll make it.
It's only up from here, baby.
Second power plant.
Let's go.
Second?
How many god clickers do you have?
Such child's play.
Imagine only having two.
Oh, yeah.
How many god clickers do you have, though?
How many god clickers do you have?
You know, one.
You know, like, one power plant equals a hundred god
clickers.
Keep up with the time.
You still gotta click.
You always have to click.
You can never stop.
It always comes down to clicking.
Competitive clicking.
What's your APM, huh?
Where's your cow PM?
My cow PM.
Cows per minute.
48 billion.
Whatever this number is, I don't know.
I don't know, man.
Okay.
63 the new esport i'm surprised there's no esports about
clicking honestly it could be huge i know you can start yeah
you can be the change yeah yes i could start the esport org
all right i have seven we should you get to go for 20 all
right i have five power plants i have seven power plants and
i'm eight now i've invested in another power plant you have
eight wait you just oh you just hit seven that's right yeah
I'm one per continent
how many five clickers do you have uh doesn't matter I have
eight cow power plants now I just opened up one up in
Antarctica behind you man you gotta get your clicks up you
gotta get your clicks all right I got another one just now I
just built another one at your home next storage to your
house what my power plant yeah yeah i built one next to your
power plant too yeah yeah i'm about to build another one oh
yeah okay i built another one again just now yeah i built
another one too i just built one i just built one oh yeah
yeah we'll build one more again i'm gonna build another one
we gotta get eye on the prize we gotta get to the 20.
oh yeah i just built another one what are you gonna do how
many do you have how many do you have um Wouldn't you want
to know?
Just look out the window.
I have just as many as you.
Guess who just got the 20 million?
The clicker.
If you did have just as many as me, you would have gotten
it.
But it looks like you did it.
Oh, you're only halfway.
You're only halfway there.
Oh, you're not even in there.
in my tax bracket.
You're not even in my tax bracket.
Oh, go talk with the little kids.
Go to the millionaire club.
I'm spending, I'm spending big.
You have no idea.
Go back to Weeny Hus Jr. Eat the cows.
Eat the cows.
Rich, just get rich.
wait oh my gosh my my clicks are going crazy oh my god i
just have two i just got two of the clicker what does it
give you it gives me like two hundred two million i can't
there's too many zeros at that point there's too many zeros
wait i'm about to get it i'm about to get it i like the
music it makes me feel stupid yeah oh dang whoa so many
clicks okay god clicker is dead everybody I just realized
that the next drop is 80 billion.
I know.
That's like easy.
That's easy.
I'm more worried from 80 to 300.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
I feel like the 80 would give us a lot, though.
I think maybe.
Yeah.
A real Nepo cow.
Oh, my God.
It gives you so much.
I need more of this.
More.
Wait.
Are you downloading an auto clicker?
What are you typing?
She's cheating!
Rep, she's cheating!
Check her PC.
Check her phone.
What is cheating if it's not using my resources?
In the 90s?
You're breaking immersion.
A real gamer would use her.
fingers now you wouldn't all right watch this guys she has
macros on wow just when i passed her tax bracket this is how
the rich get richer baby smarter not harder are you even
trying you're not cheating then You're not trying.
I'm not getting carpal tunnel over this.
Yes, more, more, more.
Okay, I'll do one more clicker.
Maybe.
Guys, this might crash my computer.
We'll see.
Yuki?
Yeah, are you actually doing it?
Are you actually getting auto clicker on it?
Yeah, I'm like sipping my coffee right now.
You're using a hot cookie.
This is what I do on Cookie Clicker too.
Oh my god.
You cheat in Cookie Clicker?
No, there's actually an achievement for cheating.
Oh, wait, really?
Yeah, it's like actually hacking it.
Oh my god.
ass run.
What are you talking about?
This quantity is...
Wait, are you at the 80 yet?
Uh, no, I'm almost there.
Oh my god.
How many clickers do you have?
Auto clickers?
No, the clickers.
I only have four.
Wait, how many auto clickers do you?
Wait a minute.
How many?
Why did you have...
Why was there a plural on that?
What did she like?
You can never handle this power.
She's min-maxing right now.
Are you ready for the 80 million?
No.
Cow earth.
Okay.
Okay, that's it.
Give me that file.
Give me that.
Send that file over.
Look, it's like, it's like tour de France, you know?
They're all, you can't, if they're all doping, then it's,
then it's fair.
It's fair, yeah.
Everyone does it.
I'm still not, I'm at, 33 billion right now.
We got equalized to playing field.
How many clickers do you have?
I was playing with integrity, but obviously, I only made a
fool of myself.
With honor and integrity.
And obviously, I didn't realize this competition was I was
giving even Evening it for myself.
Yeah, integrity.
Integrity doesn't pay the bills.
Yeah, but I'm so chill right now.
Don't you want to see the end of the cow game?
Send me the clicker file.
Send me the files.
Release the clicker files.
Release.
Here you go.
Wait, Will, let me send an EXE.
Do you think I'm saying you're a virus?
Okay, yeah.
Autoclicker.exe.
Yeah, that's it.
Okay, can you check both?
My Minecraft build real quick?
I would click it and then like...
It's actually ransomware.
Yeah.
All right, hey guys, Mint sent me a Minecraft file that we
should check out her world, guys.
I mean, it looks so fucking fake.
Like, the...
It's so bad.
It actually just says autoclicker.exe.
Windows protected your PC.
But run an unrecognized app from starting.
Run it anyway.
Do it anyway.
Just do it anyway.
Trust.
Trust you.
How do I do this?
Let's see.
One millisecond.
Pick location.
Okay.
No, don't do the pick location.
Just do the hot click, like the...
Just click F6 to start it.
F6 to start?
Yeah.
Oh, thanks for the fit together!
Thank you.
Where is it clicking, though?
You just hover your mouse over where you need to click it.
And then it'll...
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, so I'm just over top of the cow.
Wait, how...
I just click start, but it stops.
Oh Maybe you got the bad version.
You sent me this version
Don't get it.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
No, no, okay, no.
Oh my god.
Is it working?
Yeah, it's it's working Yeah, oh my god all right now it's
like game changer yeah yeah yeah i get it now no wonder i
get it now i get why they i'll get why people dope i i'm
wondering if i should get more clickers though hmm up my i'm
like i'm just doing cow i'm just doing cow earth power it's
we're going to the moon guys we're i don't know if cow earth
i mean cow earth is good but like it's only per second I
feel like I'm making I wonder can you do point nine point
zero zero one millisecond or is just one I don't know let's
try it does it work zero point oh no you can only type a
number only one millisecond that's right I distracted her
she had to type one zero point one all of a sudden.
Wait.
I'm holding a watermelon.
I don't know why.
What's going on?
I think I was hungry.
Why do I have a watermelon?
Guys, help.
Oh my gosh, I'm being hacked for real.
He has an autoclicker.exe?
No way.
What a thug.
Okay.
I don't know.
Do I go for the 300?
It's going to take forever, you guys.
Unless you have more cow herbs.
Someone's a coward.
I'm not.
How many cow herbs do you have?
Oh, yes.
There's a person that's been using an auto-clicker since the
beginning.
Not even from the beginning.
Shut up.
You wish.
I would be like crazy ahead of you.
Yeah, at the moment I was ahead you brought out you brought
out the drugs you You just you just couldn't stand the fact
that I was better than you at clicking things you No, I felt
it I just couldn't stand it Literally working smarter You're
like this is my game.
There's I'm not letting turkey bird win this one Yeah,
pretty much.
She doesn't even play clicker games.
I open cookie clicker twice a year.
Yeah, what do you do?
And so therefore, therefore I deserve this win.
The real horror is a phone game addiction.
But how many calories do you have?
At least it's not a flappy clone, a flappy bird clone.
how many how many cow orbs do you have four yeah four we
were on the same page all right yeah look at that look at
that look at that we're practically equal now to each other
we are yeah she's gonna proceed to download a second auto
clicker yeah clicking is for peasants I can hire people for
my that's true she literally out she literally got she
literally got an ai to do her clicking for her now the ai is
taking the clicking yeah they're taking our jobs not even
clicking is safe now
i think i'm gonna go for the 300.
i was already going for it i never stopped i don't give up
never back down never what
wait what's after the 300 six it's i don't know what's after
a billion kajillion wait does it go to a hundred does it go
to one it go it says it's what's wait what's more than a
billion oh trillion i have i forgot is it a kajillion
number trillion oh dang i don't even realize i'm so close
we're almost at 300 i'm getting another caliph just in case
brazilian brazilian yeah 300 brazilian isn't mintillion a
real number mintillion i don't know only apparently i only
count up to a billion i forgot about trillion
I don't even only know Zillion oh, yeah, is that after
trillion zillion it's after reptilian reptilian and then
there's Cal you Calilion Calilion yeah, that's the highest
that anybody has ever counted before mm-hmm.
Well, I was so scared of the 300 It's so easy Wait, how many
cowers did you get to get there?
I'm on seven All right, well, are you almost a 300?
No
I only need one earth I'm loyal I'm loyal to my earth
Alright let's see what it gets you Holy I don't even know
that Oh my god whoa What Oh my god what How many cows It
gives you I don't know that number I'm already at it's a cow
son It's a cow's fun.
Yeah, and I have my second.
You made a son out of cows?
You just sent like a bunch of cows to them.
I'm about to get a fourth.
Oh my god, wait, this is a game changing.
Wait, this breaks the game for real?
Wait, the 300,000?
You already got four of them?
Oh my god!
I'm only at it!
I'm still clicking!
I haven't got my first cow!
I think...
Praise the son.
Okay, I'm gonna get that six I wonder if the devs are
watching They're like, I wonder if they're enjoying the game
Wait, I'm about to get the one after cow sun You just got
the sun!
She's so greedy She's not even happy with just the sun Wait,
you have the galaxy now?
Holy Oh my god, what comes after galaxy?
I'm going for it.
Wait, I can't wait for them to port this game onto Steam.
I...
You'd think like our safe files would get trapped.
Okay, the cow sun seriously breaks the game.
Oh my god, I cannot wait to buy it.
Oh my god, I'm almost there.
You're at Supreme Clicker.
You're at Supreme Clicker?
Oh my god!
Bro, you just got the sun like three minutes ago and she has
an entire time.
multiverse now she's actually gaming what is this power
skill the power skill is broken as hell I only have one to
nerf cow son nerf cow son that's broken it actually is it
actually oh my god wait no you're right wait what the fuck
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I see now.
I see I got the cow son Yeah, once you get the cow son, it
goes insane.
Yeah, like it changes everything.
How many cows did you get?
I don't know at the moment.
It just it doesn't matter anymore.
It doesn't.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, I hope my devs have released a new
patch notes.
Oh my god, I just literally, I'm at the cow black hole.
The cow black hole.
Okay.
All right, we're...
Time is a car.
I don't, I don't know anything.
Time doesn't exist anymore.
It's just...
Okay, now I'm at the cow multiverse.
Okay, you're almost there.
Keep going, young one.
You can do it.
Eternal clicker!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Moo.
Just keep going, just keep going.
Alright, I'm clicking, I'm clicking.
I think the next one is the black hole for me.
I got the cow black hole.
I got it.
Black hole.
See, it's so fast afterwards.
What is this power scaling?
The power gap.
I felt like it took me forever to get cow earth It took us
like 20 minutes to get cow earth and then like the moment we
hit cow son the possibilities are endless There's only two
more there's only two more tears.
We could be okay.
Wait, we can beat this game.
We can beat it We change the title just to be a cow clicker
We were we were we thought it would take forever from earth,
but no we're we're here The cow sun power spike.
I like to complain to your devs about how broken cow sun is.
Please balance.
I'm team cow sun.
Your team cow sun.
Please balance the game.
It ruins the integrity, I say, as I use an auto clicker.
Okay, I'm about to get the next thing.
I'm about to get the next thing.
what's after black hole singularity clicker singularity
clicker
uh it's not as fast as i feel like it would be not as after
the cow sun hides never not the same yeah now i have to get
to a hundred it's like so much more all right i'm almost
there it's with the
how many zeros is this versus I think we've been clicking
for like 40 minutes I think so too sorry everybody but I'm
not sorry she's not yeah I do not think she's sorry if she
was sorry this would have ended 40 minutes ago you could
have ended it too and you didn't um no I can't Because if I
ended it, you win.
Eternal Cowdom is coming.
Seek salvation in cow.
In cows we trust.
Two hour game, by the way.
That's a lie.
You did not take into account about the cow clicker.
You were not balancing it for like document time.
Yeah.
You didn't expect VTubers to play.
I was like, how does this scale when Doki and Mitt play this
game?
We are playing the game.
You think they wrote this in their story, the Cow Clicker
game?
I think they wrote that they played for at least one hour of
this Cow Clicker game.
Yeah, they must have been like...
Or it wouldn't be in the game.
Exactly!
Yeah, everybody.
Oh my god, I think I actually bought like so many popes.
Oh my god.
Oh, because of the auto-clicker.
Yeah, it scrolled up and then I bought, like, pokes.
My bad.
Do I...
Actually, I think I need, like, at least five singularity
clickers, guys.
Yeah, it doesn't go fast enough.
Because we have to get 100 quadrillion.
Jillian, billion.
A Brazilian.
Okay, singularity.
singularities.
I just got my third one.
Dang it.
It's not fast enough.
It can always go faster.
It can.
It just doesn't go.
It like to get singularity takes so many clicks too.
Gold clicks.
Oh my god.
I almost bought another.
What did I buy?
Okay, I bought the singularity.
Oh my god, I have to go from the left.
I need to stop going from the right.
Every time I go from the right.
right accident then you go click something else hi i'm such
a i was like wait a second guys i'm not clicking i was about
to be like wait i'm not clicking no wonder it's so slow
wait so you weren't even using your clicks your auto clicker
was off or were you clicking it manually what's wrong with
you i was i'm clicking manually i think i'm breaking the
game dokey what's going on oh no she's got work all night
i've been i'm wired this coffee i just yeah i just drank i
finished my coffee frappuccino oh that's what you ordered
yeah Got coffee and frap.
Just what kind of frap?
You know, the one where there's coffee in it.
Where it's blended ice and coffee.
I wonder if I should go for the hundred now.
Or do I find any more singularity clickers?
Don't your fingers hurt?
Oh, no.
My fingers are like so jacked up right now.
There's a six pack on my finger.
That I'm clicking very naturally.
That's why it's so fast.
Oh, yeah.
I'm getting my 10th pack right now.
It's long enough.
I'm getting my 20 pack.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's how fast I click.
That's my Cal PM right now.
It's like...
The number doesn't even exist in the vocabulary.
That's how strong, how big it is.
That number doesn't matter to me.
All that matters to me is Cal.
That's true.
oh wait i'm already at 20 okay maybe this is doable wait 20
what 20 singularity clicker oh yeah i'm going for it i'm
going for how many singularity clickers do you have only
five only five you know why don't you invest in more because
they cost a lot yeah but then but the more you invest the
faster it goes do you not know cow nomics do you not know
cow nomics you would never give me advice you you alright
we'll see who's laughing let's see who's laughing when
they're at the top it's not about the top anymore we've gone
beyond time and space that's true we're past the black hole
Wait, all that matters is getting to the final tier.
Yeah, what's your return of cow ROI?
What are you at?
I'm at 10 singularities now.
Oh my god, I guess I could go more, but I'm fine.
Well, what's your number at?
Oh, wouldn't you want to know?
You think our parents are worried about us?
or dad is like desperately texting and he had to like be
please answer me
yeah I think she's not saying the number guys because she
can't read it because it goes beyond human comprehension
that's how fast it's going just say the first two just say
the first two the first two you won't even like you won't be
able to perceive the numbers yeah when you see it It's like,
no, it's, it's like the Indiana Jones, like they open the
chest and they die type deal.
If I say the number, like, the blinding light will hit you.
What does that happen?
Oh, you're talking about, you mean the first movie where
they open the fucking chest?
You're talking about the ending spoilers.
Oh my God.
No, I'm sorry for spoiling a 30 plus year old movie.
We're talking about Rocket the Covenant, you guys.
Oh, now you definitely spoiled the movie.
At least I didn't say the title.
Because you don't know it.
No, because I was just like, you know, that in the IJones
movie.
So people who know the ending will understand the reference.
But people who don't will get spoiled.
They'll be like, oh, I wonder which movie she's talking
about.
Well, then they wouldn't watch any of them because they knew
that they were the spoiler.
No, because it's like a little gotcha being like, oh, I
can't wait to find out which movie she's talking about.
Oh, it's big.
your clicker is lagging and even my clicker is lagging
because of my computer
i'm gonna grab one more singularity for the right road all
right now i'm just gonna let it let it ride i'm gonna catch
up to you what are you at what are you at let me know let me
know all right i'm currently at 10.
don't worry but i'm going really fast though where are you
at now Because we have to take it.
Where are you at, huh?
You wouldn't even be able to understand.
Where are you at?
Oh, I know it's not a hundred.
I know.
How do you know?
I know it's not because you would have bought the hundred.
Be like, oh, guess who just got it?
Let it count.
Spies.
Tell me right now where's Mintz at.
What are you at?
I'm at 40.
Tell me, you guys tell me right now.
I'm at 40 because I'm not embarrassed.
Oh, guess who's almost at 50?
94.
She's counting.
She's counting up right now.
97.
I'm 60, 61, 62, 63, 64, 65.
Oh, she's getting it.
How Singularity Core acquired.
How Singularity Core.
I think they...
I will say...
I will say the ending might...
The ending might be not as creative as the others.
I would...
From Singularity to Singularity Core.
I mean...
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
Also, Doki, I didn't even get an achievement for that.
You didn't get an achievement.
I think I'm done with cow game.
I think I'm pissed on.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I need to get it first, too.
It's the lordity core is kind of meh.
I don't know.
Yeah, actually, it's kind of meh.
I'm not gonna lie, actually.
It's kind of meh.
The cow singularity core.
Oh my god, it doesn't even give me that many clicks, though.
Not gonna lie.
It doesn't, it's only per second.
Yeah, it's only per second.
It's not even, of a movie is pretty mediocre.
Like, it's, like, a good build-up.
It's like, anti-climatic.
Yeah, yeah, that felt so anti-climatic, you know?
You know, I'm done.
Oh, shit.
I'm done.
I almost did record and play back.
Let me try and...
I'm done.
I think I... I'm done, yeah.
I think I'm cowed out.
Wake up.
We've been standing here for...
Wait, why did you just text me?
Why are you right here?
Oh, house cowed out.
mid
okay I have an idea what would it be really fun if we reset
our cows and started all over again
oh my god I need to get the high again yeah what were we
doing?
oh yeah we are I rented a trailer for the day and it's
almost nighttime
wait how do you like oh hide in the trailer oh We're gonna
have to hide here.
Wait, did you see our mic beat?
I just noticed the mic meter.
I noticed our mic.
We're so dead.
We're so fucking dead.
What am I supposed to do?
Wait, I had tools.
I forgot our task.
Hello?
Oh, she's...
That girl's creepy.
Are you kissing her?
you're my boyfriend aren't you what the hell are you doing
with her that thing that she made a move on me i was just
trying to think of the trash see no you were no no no no no
no she made a move on me i'm faithful who spent who spent
one hour cooking cows with you huh who was it that's true
that's true that's right don't worry i'll water our carpet
anyway so we're just deep cleaning we're it was called
cleaning simulator yeah yeah yeah wait do we actually need
to what do we need to do i don't know it's just all my goal
it's just cows oh wait i need i was trying to change my oh
my god there's no sensitivity you can't change your sense in
this game no you can't oh you have to grab i think we
actually have to pack oh shit okay wait it's just you have
to pack again oh my god yet the best just packing simulator
we're prepping you for it tonight all right where are the
others i can talk to you one down oh it's one more one more
oh wait there's a basement scary yeah wait yeah i got it all
right let's go you've my lady first you took on boo come on
go down i'm here i will shine it in front of you see there's
light down here exactly all right they said one left grab
that they said one left min maxing i need two it's two to
grab come here come here okay come on i need you here see
what's up what's up uh this one okay gotta be careful let's
go come on i am come on come on oh my god i'm dropping it
i'm dropping yeah you good over there yeah no i'm asking you
oh you're fine all right okay come on oh it's dropping i
think i'm moving it come on i'm moving it i'm moving oh it's
gonna drop i think
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Wait, grab it!
Here!
Oh, oh, wait, can we jump over it?
Uh-oh.
Wait, wait, wait, I got this.
Uh, you're Tanya.
You're Tanya.
I got this.
I got...
Wait, don't touch anything!
I got it!
I got it, I got it, got it, got it.
I got it.
I'm such a good boyfriend.
I'm so good at this moving shit.
Yeah, come over.
Help me out.
Yeah, but then you'll you won't learn how to do it yourself.
You got to be independent.
Oh my god.
Come on All right, why are you like tilting it all over the
place?
Oh, okay.
All right.
You think I'm tilting it?
You think I'll show you what tilting is Oh, who the fuck is
this guy?
I had to have some time Yeah, you too Yeah, I thought you're
just supposed to delete this morning we might have put we
might have downloaded cow clicker
okay a little blind packing took too
we're just yeah packing took too long longer than expected
almost done wait is there a way a jump in this game yeah
there is how oh okay now uh i don't know i don't know i
don't know bro but at this point it's happening either way
just want to get moving at this point it's nice mullet whoa
you know this was the 90s last night was fun man yeah next
time we're back yeah bro well you two need a hand with
anything oh my god thanks though okay okay i was just oh my
god they should write a story about us and then have us act
voice act oh my man yeah peace out i'll miss you too yeah
get me out of here she's trapping are you hitting on him no
wow on the last day smile you're on camera what do we need
to do now
We just...
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck did you do?
Autoclicker not like...
Wait, do I... do we just drive?
Wait, here let me try, let me try.
Okay, wait, wait.
Oh, you're an autoclicker clock.
Oh shoot, we can go!
Oh shit, wait, we can go!
wait where are we going where
are we going I don't know I'm turning on some jams though
dang I wasn't the best at driving I should have let Marcus
drop yeah yeah you get back behind them I wonder why I
wonder why you're on it's not as easy as it looks okay oh
wait I'm Wait, we left our suitcase in the garage.
Wait, we have a suit.
We left something in the garage.
Not like we left.
Okay, okay, okay.
We got, where's our house?
By the way.
Oh, yeah, I told them they were saying like they were asking
me about driving, saying like, I'm a bad driver.
And then I was like, wait, what was it?
I actually forgot the punchline.
anyway i'm i'm a streamer guys we're gonna get our stuff
from the garage all right how to get out oh space to get up
yeah yes space all right i'm going grab stuff
no they said we forgot our suitcase in the garage in the
basement.
Wait, but there's more boxes.
They said, I don't fucking know.
There's like boxes at the bottom, too.
At least you can park.
Oh.
What other boxes are we missing?
Are you bringing a fridge?
Or Samsung fridge?
Oh, now you open the door.
Alright.
I'm gonna...
Why?
The music got spookier when I put the fridge in oh yeah make
sure you deep clean it we'll have to pay for a cleaning fee
it's a power wash simulator yeah yeah all right i'll grab
the other boxes i'm pretty sure this is the last one wait no
no is there any more boxes
oh no no no no no no no no all right have we got everything
right did you find this box wait there's literally one in
the kitchen too stop stop oh it says fragile i can't read
clearly oh wait there is one more box my god why did you buy
all this Shit!
All right, we got this box.
That wasn't in that fragile, guys.
Microwave, we need our microwave!
Oh, that's so true.
I'm not buying a new microwave.
Is there anything else?
Can I take my bathtub with me?
Wait, our toaster.
Oh my God, our toaster.
We cannot forget our toaster.
How are we gonna make bread?
Did you get the air fryer?
Alright.
Wait, was air fryer's invented back then?
I don't own an air fryer!
Nice.
Alright, do we get everything?
That should be everything, right?
We have boxes for a reason!
Was there anything outside?
Oh wait, how am I gonna barbecue, though?
Honestly.
A man needs his barbecue set.
Okay, I think that's everything.
You're lugging?
Are we good?
Do we get everything?
All right, I'll drive.
What about the suitcases in the garage, you said?
I think we got it, right?
Wait, how did you drive?
I just went.
Oh, wait, there's a GPS.
Oh, okay, bye.
Okay, bye.
All right, all right, get in here.
I'm in.
Oh, shh.
All right, all right, all right.
It's like a drive-by.
You got this.
We have a killer with us.
You got to practice this.
Okay.
When the killer's chasing us.
I'm in.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me open my GPS.
All right, for legal reasons, I did not indulge in texting
and driving.
Okay, I...
All right, where are we going?
Where are we going?
I don't know.
I can't text and drive.
It's not.
Yeah, that's not immersive.
It's not immersive.
Don't you miss it in the 90s when you get texted?
Everybody was texting and driving.
Everybody was doing it in the 90s.
Oh, I think we gotta get the trailer.
Oh, shit.
Get up, get up, get up.
Get me out.
Yeah.
Okay.
Two hours long game, everybody.
All right.
Oh, there's a car honking at you.
wait just wait we're moving
oh my god be patient oh shit
all right now we got an exchange license plates now
okay all right sir, please get out so we can exchange
license plates.
Clearly it was his fault, right?
Come on, Tessa.
It was his fault.
I had the right of way.
I'm going to save this.
Wait.
What scene am I in?
Did I get in the backseat?
Wait, I can't get out.
I
have women.
Am I right, guys?
Oh, yeah.
All right, we did it, guys.
Oh my god, these people are so impatient.
Out of my way!
She says that she drives on the wrong side of the road.
Ooh, no, and driving is so high.
Okay, I gotta go now.
How do we go?
By the way, guys, I was in the car with men as a driver, by
the way.
And I survived.
This is it.
This is the run.
Yeah, yeah.
She had.
I was in the car with her while she was driving, guys.
I did drive a new one.
Yeah.
And I lived to tell the tale.
Wait, here.
We can connect it here.
Hook it.
We can connect it.
That's what I'm saying.
close are we close enough no what do you think you're on the
side what what do you think car was parked a little too far
at first a hug you might be a little too far yeah maybe I
should sit in Okay.
It's safer, right?
My passenger, princess.
Oh, she likes to go.
For legal reasons, I did not indulge in texting and driving.
Yeah, that's what I got, too.
Okay, where am I going?
I don't know.
I have, it says no route selected.
We missed loading some of our stuff at first.
Wait, what do you mean?
What did we miss?
I'm waiting.
Let's go.
What did we miss?
We got everything.
I'm checking.
I like how he left all the doors.
Oh, our luggage!
Our...
Our luggage.
It was right here.
It was right.
Oh, yeah.
The luggage.
Wait, come help me with this couch.
Marcus.
Oh, we are bringing our couch.
Wait, a little help?
Wait, this is not gonna fit.
Yeah, it would.
Watch this.
I wasn't trying to lift it like anything.
As you were like hunched over.
I told you.
We make it fit.
A man needs his coat.
Grab it!
I'm trying!
Why are you letting go?
Because you were letting go!
I don't know what you're talking about.
job oh okay yeah i saw that it's because you're not working
fast enough come on come on this is repo we're playing
that's how i looked earlier we had to open i had to open
this yeah apparently marcus is heavy okay where's the
luggage apparently it should have been like on the oh oh my
god oh i clipped through it i i think i did after you wait
where's our luggage apparently we should have been in the
trunk so i'm trying to find it oh well what did you do oh no
i don't where did it go did i like chuck it and transport it
into the wait there's this is here is that our luggage no no
it was it was like oh i threw it all the way in there okay
we gotta like i'm gonna go check for anything else all right
i gotta re-tetris this.
Wait, where is our luggage?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, I got it.
Alright.
And then...
Just move over!
Oh my god.
And then we put this up here.
Boop.
We gotta re-tetris this for our couch.
I think that's everything.
oh wait found a box where did you find that box yeah that's
what i'm saying all right now we get the couch i got i got
this in okay okay all right all right go on in you go wait
how do i get out you're good you're good you're good i'll
make you no clip through oh that's true okay drum all right
um this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Unless... Oh, I did it.
Wait, it's not going in.
No!
How are we gonna get in the couch?
Okay, we got a Tetris this.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Maybe we could fit.
Oh, are you okay?
Are you okay?
I don't know what just happened to me.
You like tripped and fell.
You know, like, life alert?
Okay, hold on.
Our toaster is really important, but it can go in the back.
Alright.
Okay, it's lid.
Alright, hold on.
We're so good at packing.
We're still in the tutorial.
Oh, you need...
We're still in the tutorial right now.
Oh, she clipped out.
She clipped out.
I like how...
Why is it all green?
If you right-click it, they're all green.
This is sick.
Look into the trailer when you right-click.
whoa that's probably stuff we need to grab it's like a hint
oh my god i'm green i'm right clicking everything i'm right
clicking i'm doing the meta the meta strat the meta i think
that's everything all right so we don't need our couch i'm
glad i ordered coffee guys i i think i i would not survive I
ordered coffee.
I do not think I would have survived this stream
All right, I'm right.
Let's just leave the couch on the road.
We're not bringing the couch man.
We're gonna buy a new couch, Tessa Okay Yeah, it's in the
back you drive you drive I'll drive okay.
Yeah, that's right Clearly the superior driver should take
the front seat Yeah, I kept telling me that Marcus should
drive every time I got the two guys.
Wait, we missed loading something.
What did we miss?
It's the couch.
There's no way it's the couch.
Oh my god, there's no way.
Uh-oh, guys.
Oh my god.
Apparently we do need the couch.
We gotta retetress this.
Are you okay?
I can't get up.
Wait, wait.
I have an idea.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
What are you doing?
Stop!
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to drive!
I'm just reaching over in a pocket.
Okay, okay, can you get out?
Can you get out now?
There we go.
I just... I don't know.
I threw the car a little bit to the left.
Okay.
Okay, we got him.
under okay i think like we have to put all these stuff out
and then put the couch in no no no i'm just moving it to the
back i'm moving to the back here let's move this a little
bit yeah yeah yeah okay oh there you go i'm gone now i don't
think it's gonna i think we made it worse i think we made it
worse all right i'm doing it Okay, okay, let's try, let's
try, let's try, let's try We got this, we got this This is a
moving simulator at this point It's this goddamn bomb Okay,
wait, wait, wait Who's blocking the room?
Who is it?
It's because we're blocking the room
Maybe we do have to take everything out Oh, yeah, now, wait,
wait, wait, wait Oh my god, I'm out of the car I'm out of
the fucking truck Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait This is
it This is it No, okay, oh, somebody made it work okay okay
okay we gotta get rid of this box no no no not this one oh
my god okay fine fine we gotta get rid of that oh my this is
what they wanted oh how did that happen oh guys women am i
right
no no that's fine we've Just push the bed.
We have so much space.
We have so much space for the couch.
All right, all right.
You're on the other side.
This is the horror aspect trying to move.
And then it has to pack after the stream.
I know.
There, we did it.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh, we're going to clip through the screen.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay, easy.
All right, easy.
Okay, I'm trying to...
Oh, my God.
Oh, where am I?
Okay, we have one more box.
One more box.
There we go.
All right, that's everything.
It's everything.
Oh, my God.
There you go.
What's going on with you?
Yeah, what's going on with you?
Why am I so tall?
Don't tell me it's nothing.
Can we just go?
Oh, you're the ghost.
What happened yesterday?
Wait, why do I have a knife all of a sudden?
I said I'm fine, Marcus.
Yeah, are you fine?
Hey, man.
Yeah.
We have 15 minutes till it hits two hours.
You think?
We drive out of the house and the game ends.
Probably.
Yeah, that was the whole thing.
Yeah.
I'm serious.
When did I get it?
I said stop.
All right.
What is it?
Can it just not be right now?
Why is she being so emotional?
Hell no, something happened last night.
Oh.
She downloaded cow clicker last night.
That's what happened.
She's like, you used an auto clicker and I was trying to
play barely.
not talk to me you're like um cloud clicker was my thing and
you just had to ruin my thing didn't you you just you got
better at it than me and i'm just really emotional right now
you had your gardening and i had cow clicker and you just
had to ruin it for me
Oh my
god.
There's so many guys.
Oh my god.
Also, I hope...
I didn't check if the audio was good, so I hope the audio
has been good the entire time.
I'm sure it's fine.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Well, now we can leave.
Oh, now they leave.
What's wrong with them?
Why can't I start the car?
Wait, just start the car.
We made good time on the loading.
Right, we made good time.
Shut the door.
Bye.
Why can't I turn on my car?
Oh, that's the radio?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, let me check.
Check the navigator.
Yeah, check the navigator.
It doesn't show anything.
Oh, okay.
All right.
I think...
I don't know.
I'm just driving.
Oh!
It's Fade of Black.
We're loading in.
7.40 p.m.
We made good time, guys.
Credits roll.
Hello?
Hi.
Hey.
I think it's...
think oh it's on 205 west for two miles four hours I thought
this was a two-hour game yeah it's like real-time driving
any bathroom breaks um Tessa says she's okay warning
prepared to meet goo what
That sign just said prepare to meet goo Oh DJ dashy can we
turn off the music please?
Um, this is We got a situation Um I saw the road don't keep
it Oh, wait, wait, I have a text for my dad Wait, wait,
wait, wait, I got it I got it Got check my text me.
Yeah, he texts me keep me updated Marcus.
Oh Alright, that's all he said you're driving?
Yeah.
This is such...
This is so bad.
Oh, I got a message from Marcus.
Oh, shit.
He didn't message me.
Yeah, your dad doesn't love you.
Like, how he loves me.
That's exactly what I was typing.
Yeah, pass that guy.
Pass that guy.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm going to give him the finger as you do it.
Oh, shit.
my god doggy it's like bumper cars who's honking at us i
know this has a decent kitchen apparently the guy said it
was recently oh take exit five take exit five okay exit five
who texted you that figured you'd like having more the
navigator oh okay friends nobody else texts me except the
navigator your wife is back what your wife is hot oh shit oh
my good i know it helps you when you're right wait don't
forget to take exit five where's exit okay you're supposed
to look it for me and there's an exit here it's right now oh
right here okay there you go i i think i i think i turned my
blinker on you think it hit stay on this for 40 miles 40
miles yeah keep going sorry look at that pcs yeah trying to
be a gamer yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna be a i'm gonna be the
next big streamer on What's the one pre-Twitch?
I don't remember.
Traffic bad?
Could be worse.
Terrible.
Alright.
Why am I swerving to the left?
I don't know.
Our alignment's bad.
Something's pushing me to the left.
Yeah, Justin TV.
Yeah, that's...
Yeah, I'm gonna be the next big streamer at Justin TV.
What is Justin TV?
It was basically... That is Twitch before Twitch.
God, yes, used to be called Justin TV.
Ah, because I'm a gamer.
I know my history.
Never forget your history, where you came from.
I never came from Twitch.
Never forget where you came from.
Oh, I got...
Oh, important traffic alert.
Oh, it's congested.
I'll reroute.
I'm looking for a new route.
I'm glad you're doing your job.
Take the exit to Cascade Highway.
Cascade Highway.
in um 0.8 miles all right we're 60 miles away from it oh
this feels like final destiny oh oh new message oh new
message i would stop this car right now i would in
the car wait i have someone i'm texting oh i can't get up
that's looking right
what says you're typing are you No, no.
Oh, it's creepy.
Oh, that's where the ghost is.
That's the ghost.
Yeah.
.
Oh
He's just my coach.
Oh, yeah, your late night coaching coaching session.
Yeah, that's what they all say Yeah, the late night coach
sessions Where were you last day?
It's a late night coaxing.
Get in the car.
Wait, I think that's our exit.
Yeah.
Is that our exit?
Okay.
It was literally right next door.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know why I'm swearing.
I swear to God, I'm not clicking anything.
What?
It's a ghost!
Oh, that's it!
You're driving!
You drive!
Okay, I'll drive!
Wait, it won't let me out of the car!
Get out!
It won't let me out!
Oh my god.
I swear to God, you text me right now, I swear to God.
Whoa!
I want to get home!
All right, here we go.
Oh, hey, there's cow crossing.
Do you see that?
No, where?
No, well, too late.
Too late.
Guess she's not going to see it.
Eight.
Only took us one hour.
Eight, oh, 8 p.m.
It only took us one hour to get there.
We're here.
No, we're not.
We're still driving.
Stay on the highway for 2.7 miles.
Okay, that's fine.
That should be fine.
Are you sober?
Are you safe to drive?
Yeah.
See, there's...
Oh, no, that's not Cal Crossing.
Oh, there's...
No, that's Avalanche.
Yeah, Avalanche.
Oh, I got a message from my dad.
Who's texting you?
I got it's my dad!
It's not my dad.
Sorry, pops.
What's the update?
Your uncle still owe me $40, by the way.
Okay, I'll read it for you.
Um, sorry pops interstate had a blockage so we're taking a
detour through Roseberry that you know once we get back to
the main road I was stuck on the interstate and there's not
a single car on this road.
Yeah, where are the cars?
I know wait Yeah, one passed by, no?
Yeah Let me let me get out.
Let me get out.
Let me see how in our text.
Okay, he gave me a thumbs up Wait, this is not the 90s Why
do we have like this phone is not why don't GPS in the 90s I
love texting on my phone in the 90s guys Why are you running
into the why are you so my with my touchpad
You're stuck in here with me
Okay, here we go.
I was gonna say, where's my blueberry?
Like, where's my blueberry phone or blackberry?
Is it blackberry?
Yes, because it's copyrighted.
We don't want to get sued.
You're so right.
Um, Okay, you just keep going straight.
Keep going straight.
Yeah, it's like the Samsung, the Samsung fridge.
Oh, remember our Samsung fridge in the in the trailer?
Oh, we gotta leave.
Are you okay?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Now you can get up.
I'm okay.
Yeah.
Deep breath.
What do we do?
We're moving it.
We're moving the tree.
Don't worry.
I have a 10 pack from Cal, clicker.
Yeah, me too.
Me too.
You can shift it enough to get through.
How do we move it?
All right.
I'm grabbing it.
grabbing the end well you're actually grabbing the we're
gonna move an entire tree I
don't know we're moving this tree is that fine I think
that's fine right I think that's fine right yeah yeah go
through go to the left this feels like a moving game.
Women in STEM!
What the fuck do you see that?
Wait, wait, there's somebody running.
Yeah, did you see that?
Yeah, I saw that.
Wait, let's talk to him.
He opened our thing!
He's so- Wait!
Wait!
Did he store stuff?
Wait, where did he go?
Did he steal our stuff?
Did he steal our CRT-TV?
How am I playing my Nintendo games?
How am I gonna play Smash Bros?
You were just looking at a PC.
Yeah, but Smash Bros.
hasn't come out yet on Steam.
Valve hasn't made Steam yet.
I think we should go after him.
Where did he go?
This way.
But this is probably his car.
We rob him back.
Oh, that's true.
I'm taking his...
Wait, he was a gardener.
It's a handyman.
Oh, let's just get back to the car.
Yeah, let's just go.
Yeah.
late what if another tree falls down all right you drive i'm
tired now
don't make me pull this far you have to navigate me now uh
for one mile okay just go straight yeah just go straight
okay whoa that's a train yeah uh 0.7 miles okay Look at
that.
We're gaming.
Oh, see, there is another car.
See, it's not too bad.
What were you worried about?
Yeah.
Yeah, what were you worried about?
I would be worried about trees falling.
Oh, poor two miles to the right.
Oh, just no one.
No, it's not.
It's all right.
It's just someone I know from work, you know.
Oops.
Oh, yeah.
And you were talking about my driving.
Couldn't even do a right turn.
Did you turn your blinker on?
I'm gonna crash this car.
I'm gonna crash it.
I'm flooring it right now.
I'm flooring it and we're gonna go off the bridge.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
What is that?
That was not me.
A light on the dash came on.
Oh, yeah.
Because you started driving.
Oh, now look at that.
Ever since the men started driving.
I feel this car struggle on the hill.
No, this is is a setup this is a because men started driving
suddenly all these problems came up guys i didn't get i
didn't get any of these issues before when i was driving the
game was a good shot oh look at that you're getting honked
at now look at that oh uh oh look at why is your door
Is this a chase scene?
It just go around me.
Oh no!
Our car is on fire!
Oh no, our car broke down!
I'm going?
Wait, actually I can't go.
Well, you gotta fix the car.
I actually stuck.
Uh...
Hold on.
There we go.
Okay, alright.
Alright, we're good.
We're okay.
We're driving.
Don't worry about the engine fire.
Don't worry about it.
They can go to this motel All I'm saying I'm saying the game
didn't complain when I oh now we have two people.
Oh, you're hot.
You're the one that's hot I'm putting on music.
Yeah.
Oh, he went around.
Oh, you finally went around.
What was the deal with that guy?
Yeah, yeah, bitch Okay, um, the light.
What are we doing?
Not even the light, the smoke?
Yeah, the smoke on the engine?
Go away?
These trees are hanging real low.
This is new 4.
Yeah, we're playing a 4-Z game.
I can't believe 4-Z has multiplayer.
8.50.
Oh, it didn't go away.
She drove for a few more minutes before we accepted the car
wasn't going to fix itself.
I found the only shop in the area on GPS.
The other survivor is still reading.
No, no, no, no, no.
You were still reading.
Yeah, my team was telling me how much of a bad driver you
were.
It was like three pages long.
It was giving me like a step-by-step of how bad your driving
was.
No, mine was that.
Mine said how many times you ran into them.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's why it was so fast for you to.
read because it was like one sentence oh i have text
messages from dad times that the damn car overheated not
sure what we're going to do we found a service station i'm
going to say about getting the car fixed wait is that the
service station uh no route selected was that the service
station it's a gas station so i think so i don't know it
could be it's gotta be all right all Ah, car troubles.
Classic horror.
Do we...
Nothing could prepare us for what came next.
Is it here?
I guess.
We ain't go.
Help us!
Hello, sir!
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, echo, yeah.
Oh, hey, there's my Mar- Mar- Mar-lo.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Hello, anybody here?
Oh, hair dye.
Oh Oh, oh Match the carpet with the drapes.
Oh my god.
Say hello to ginger Oh, there's so hello.
Hello
So we're no I think we're supposed to go over there anybody
here.
I think we go to the light, right?
Yeah Boo the sun says open someone's got to be around here
this place smells weird it smells weird here it's not like
gas because we're next to a gas station wait my heart's
beating is your heart beating yeah howdy do you want to talk
car needs fixing yeah yeah Actually, we were driving up and
had a light come on in the dash about 20 minutes back.
It's the red one.
We were hoping someone here could take a look.
Temperature light?
Maybe.
I don't fucking know anything about cars.
No.
You're going to upcharge us.
It was.
Uh, we're headed north.
Actually, we're just headed up north.
He got a new job.
That's right.
I got promoted.
Yeah.
yeah I'm gonna be a CEO here knows about cars don't see a
lot of what huh of what what what what's wrong with us a
long way from anywhere you could they don't see a lot of
women and then I guess black people it's just oh I follow me
let's follow him.
Okay, we're following him.
Oh, he's following us.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, to the car.
To the car.
Wait, I got... Okay.
Was it making any way?
Alright, let's go.
He's walking.
He's, like, staring at me, though.
Yeah, I don't like that.
I don't like that he's staring at you.
Hey, that's my woman!
Hey!
Oh, wait.
That's right.
Don't worry, I'll stand behind you, my lady.
last night was a maze balls you guys my manners my name is
harold harold sweeney y'all can just sweeney oh my god yeah
we have to see sweeney died is this the cow coach you were
texting last day was this him always cow and his house
interest in match braver you really what does that mean
by the way just so you know okay I was just doing some
scraping work yeah she dated out of her cow circle yeah yeah
she was a competitive cow clicker she wouldn't think she
would settle for someone that just started in the game
she's take him to the car he's waiting for you why who are
you texting who are you texting it's Ellie you wouldn't
understand all right coffee break all right where is he oh
good he was a scalper oh my god oh It's on fire.
It's on fire.
Take that wrench and bang it.
Bang that wrench.
I mean, I could have done the same thing, you know?
Let's see what's going on here.
Yeah, why don't you make yourself useful?
I'm lagging.
How are you lagging?
He's just looking at the car.
How are people different as you get together?
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
not sure I follow yeah what are you trying to say I mean I
was I mean cow clicker was my first mobile game um he's like
I start I'm I'm more used to girls starting with flappy cow
yeah I think I found the problem but just a second yeah we
don't need small talk just fix the yeah just fix our car we
have We have a cow convention to go to.
Am I the problem?
That's what I figured.
What?
What is it?
I think I can help you out.
What?
What's wrong?
Wait, what's wrong with the car?
That's my man.
Racist!
I was so chill about that too.
Either of you notice anything before it died on it.
I started it started struggling up the hill it started
struggling on the hill the temperature needle shot up out of
nowhere yep that lines up who the hell is that whoa shit
okay hey get on up here who's this guy all right I will stay
right here he doesn't want to fix her car he's trying to
charge us like 20 times he knows I know nothing about cars
he's trying to sell our he's trying to get our couch yeah
yeah he's trying to get oh wait did you get text yeah yeah
what is it daddy our car broke down wait i just gotta think
maurie called me you two left the garage door open
dad that's not the issue that's not the issue here i think
they're talking about us probably let's go over there and
check it out oh he's coming back coming back hey hey oh got
another text I wish you'd called sweetie you too need yeah
what what he said he said wait wait you go back into the
house and come back take care of it oh my god you have an
echo now shape then I thought it looks like the head gasket
is about to go out whole things kind of up uh you said you
had the parts though we oh that that man looks even more
yeah this this guy oh wait it's walter white oh it's what oh
he is wait where are we gonna do his races walter white is
it the best it's because this is not a real gas station
that's true that is it oh but i retired a few years back oh
this guy okay harry still does some work at his house Oh,
you want us to go to his house?
Car, Harry, we gotta cook.
Car won't make it, though.
Yeah.
The car won't make it any further.
Actually, this happened to me not too long ago on the
highway.
Oh, yes.
Harry will do a little patch job on the engine.
That'll get you as far as Bill's house.
That'll get you as far as the people's house.
You're looking at...
smokes yeah this guy smokes like per second yeah the SPM
smokes a minute Harry Harry what was it yeah he commands him
damn welcome to books 24 hours 24 hours monitoring I don't
want to give him money no good we go to the bathroom I want
to Oh Yeah, I need to use the restroom.
Just got to hit the bathroom before we leave.
Yeah bathrooms for customers customers Oh, yeah, I'll buy
something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll grab a snack just wanted to look around maybe grab a
snack and then I can be a customer What oh my god.
Oh my god.
He's a bug.
I'm a customer.
Wait, what if I what if I yeah, what if she goes in?
He can't be sexist and racist Wait, he doesn't even want to
talk to you.
Yeah, wait, he can't He had me!
He is sexist and racist!
Oh my god!
There's no way he can be both!
Yes he can!
This guy plays cigarette clicker.
He's both?
Thanks for nothing, Harry.
Yeah, thanks for nothing, Harry.
Fucking whipped us hell.
Look at that!
We're gonna show you something crazy!
A woman driver!
Look at that!
We're so progressive!
I'm a good one.
Here we go.
We are progressive.
How do I start my car?
It's cat's date night after I told him about woman driving.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, that's funny.
Oh, dog.
It's okay.
She meant to do that, guys.
Wait, where am I going?
I need you to navigate me.
No route selected.
I assume you just go straight.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, but there's a turn here.
I don't fucking know my GPS just says Tell me where to go Go
straight We have to show up for that We have to show them
We're about to get hit by this Trump I think we go straight
Right We can't go back I said you are a great driver We got
proof I am I am I'm making it I'm making it Alright then we
just go straight And then it'll give us like a blackout
cutscene It'll fade to black or something So true You're
right yeah yeah it's gonna fade to black any minute now any
oh i got text messages keep me in the loop long story short
they couldn't fix the car but said some guy named bill can
take a look where is bill's house oh i thought i was fading
the black earlier oh is it here no no i don't know no
trespassing we go straight but it said not to what go on the
highway uh who's bill some mechanic they said we are almost
here i'll text you go to sleep all right yeah any minute now
any minute fade of black oh oh oh the car couldn't take the
climb anymore oh uh uh uh here i'll just keep going forward
i think i think it's at the back this is an invisible wall
oh okay so we missed the turn we definitely missed the turn
okay all right don't worry the car will fix itself when
we're off that road yeah yeah yeah there you go so slow
though yeah it's like a little like it's like magic actually
it's just the hill going down i'm not even i'm not even on
the all right it's fine okay he's it doesn't it doesn't move
anymore where the fuck is bill where are those where are we
supposed to go i don't know how my navgo isn't working you
know what is working what cow clicker no no i need you right
now doggy stop oh wait the car is moving again all right
nice nice i'm gonna click some cows this is why cow clicker
exists guys but whenever it builds house right is that
bill's house it says no trespassing but i think it's fine oh
yeah yeah that's true that's where it's the spooky stuff
happens that should be He's probably really kind, and we'll
fix the car for...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, that means we're going the right way, because it's
progressing.
Oh, you're right.
Wait, I don't think it's the right way.
The car broke down.
No, I didn't.
I'm checking my text.
Hey, kiddo, don't leave me hanging.
We are near Roseburg.
We found a mechanic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had a similar text for my dad, too.
That's what you call her.
Daddy.
You call her daddy.
Wait, why?
Wait, what was that?
That's your text.
Glad you're not doing this alone.
Why is the music all like?
Wait, that has to be where Bill is, right?
This has to be.
Yeah, that's Bill's place.
Oh, yeah, I hear it.
I hear it.
All right, let's get out.
Why is it like this?
Maybe Bill's here.
Hello?
Yeah, yeah, do you hear that violin going crazy?
Yeah, it's going crazy.
Yeah, it's like, weeer.
All right.
Um, because I think, um, I think you should not.
Yeah, yeah, you're like the better.
Oh, I tried opening the door.
I just tried opening the door.
Yeah, I'm gonna stand over to the side just in case.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They have a welcome mat.
They're probably probably.
You know, I don't want to get, get, you know, you know the
movie Get Out?
Oh,
hello.
Uh-oh.
Wait, she's kind of goofy.
The instrument of his wrath myself.
If you don't get off my porch.
Uh-oh.
Uh.
You got the wrong idea.
I think you got the wrong idea.
You're not from the new temple.
The new temple?
Marcus, what did I tell you?
Stay over there.
We're looking for Bill.
Yeah, we're looking for Bill.
Tell her we're looking for Bill.
Billy boy.
You at the door.
Oh, Billy boy's a little social.
It shows silly awkward.
How do you know?
Billy boy's little shy.
We go find him.
Billy boy.
Must be the ones Buck warned me about.
Oh, what?
Yeah, he called.
Since the folks were stranded and heading my way.
Okay, good.
Okay, that's good.
He's gonna help, right?
Then you know, yeah, you know.
Yeah, yeah, he knows.
That's us.
That'd be us.
I'll say.
The station told us it was probably a coolant leak, then
backed out and wouldn't fix it.
Could you please take a look, sir?
Hey, Billy.
See, look, the moment I started talking, he was not very
happy.
Yeah.
What do you...
You can't see the car from here.
Yeah, it's over here.
Engine's hot as hell.
Oh, that's my bad.
If you're lucky, you've got a coolant leak.
If you ain't...
It's a blown head gasket and your oil's turning into soup.
Oh, no.
What?
Didn't even take a look.
Yeah.
I've been fixing engines longer than y'all been alive.
I know what I'm looking at.
But you don't know.
I have a custom engine in here.
Yeah, what if...
Yeah, what...
Oh, you should use.
Yeah, what do we do now?
What do we do till morning?
I ain't running a motel here.
sleep in your car out here if you want oh i but okay
actually i don't want to go in there that's true oh okay
well i guess we're sleeping inside the high power wouldn't
have sent you here if we weren't meant to take care of you
all right all right okay let's you're right where you are to
be oh that's not creepy at all let me in come on i bet she
makes a mean pie i bet she i bet she Yes, I bet she makes a
fresh pat.
Yeah, who's Miss Julia?
Yeah, who's she?
Miss Julia?
She's just a sweet old lady who runs a bed and breakfast up
the hill.
I have to go up the hill now?
We're needy?
Um, I got promoted.
That's right.
Like, y'all.
The great.
We got upgraded to a new tax bracket.
To rest.
Yeah.
Or how do we get it there?
Where is her place?
Yeah.
distance actually i'm not sure if this car should even move
anymore your friend buck told us it'd be a catastrophic
engine failure you won't be needing your car to get there
take this little trail behind the house we're going in the
okay are we going on the flashlight yeah yeah flashlights oh
it's a little spooky i don't like that she said like that i
know yeah a little spooky don't step off it not even once
you won't like what happens what happens if you know what
I'm gonna trap it's booby trap now I really want to step on
it you can't tell me what to do folks walk it plenty at
times it's a straight shot you'll know it when you reach
there why you guys aren't a cult right that's such a boring
I mean she said I mean she said the others the out and
there's another cult though like the tempo yeah yeah yeah
maybe it's See, that's what they want.
It's been like rival cults, maybe.
Like, my cult is better than your cult.
It's like...
We're the cult of cow.
Have you ever heard of us?
All right, I guess we go to the trail now.
It's at the back of the house.
With something, I think.
Oh, he was.
Yeah.
Oh, it's the flashlight.
What do we just...
I packed our flashlight.
Yeah, we did catch it.
Battery's good.
Don't drop it.
Okay.
All right.
That's enough.
for tonight.
Trails back there and goes right up the hill.
Don't waste time.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go!
Oh.
Come on now, Charlotte.
Missing our program.
Alright, let's go.
Is that the trail?
I double- I double dared- I double dared you to get off the
trail.
Oh my god, she's doing it, guys!
She's so wild!
Your turn your turn not going up there.
No, you got you got to say true for there
It's your turn true for there that we've never heard of
there town.
We've never heard of well.
I tripled there double dare you to get off the trail again
She's so wild guys.
She's crazy I don't know that Harry.
I don't know any of you Wait, there's an invisible wall.
Wait, we forgot to get the suitcase.
Oh, yeah, our suitcase.
Okay, let's get it.
We're even seriously fine with this?
Two strangers we just met pointing us down a dark trail and
you're just...
Yeah, I'm fine with it.
I'm not fine.
I'm so fine.
We're pretty chill.
Okay, I hold the... Yeah, yeah, I hold the suitcase like a
man.
Wait, do I need mine?
No, you're fine.
Okay, we're good.
It means you just decide and expect everyone to follow.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm a man!
What's happening to us?
We're just badgering?
What happened last night?
What happened?
I thought last night was a maze balls.
The job, the apartment, your studio, all of it.
it was oh oh what is my job i did find it and i am moving to
washington like this was something you were doing and i just
happened to be coming along i just we're fighting in the
dark woods yeah i don't know i don't want to feel like i'm
along for the i dare you to go off the trail that's on oh i
didn't even realize oh yeah Oh my god, look, I'm off the
trail Whoa, fucking wires You're not along for the ride Stop
making decisions like I am I hear you, okay?
I hear you, but right now Right now, we need to make a
decision Look how she wants to argue In the forest at the
middle of the night Right Like this could have been like in
the What was it?
The breakfast Bed and breakfast place I know, right?
We're just doing it I already have the suitcase suitcase oh
my god i'm running ahead i'm running ahead we falling on
paper things looks pretty bleak for us i know a relationship
it's crumbling but the only help in town was the stay up the
hill oh let's dive i dare you to go pet him where is he
let's go let's go get him all right i don't think i think
he's up the hill isn't he Oh, there's an invisible wall.
There's, like, no doggo for you.
Sounds like a man trying to be a dog.
Oh!
It sounds like a fox.
Like...
Can I hit your ride?
Wait, can you actually...
Oh, dang it.
Oh, all right.
Scratch...
Oh!
Tidal drop.
drop i'm sorry about last night i didn't think about how
that sounded yeah my feelings look we are going to
washington does that make you feel better now we are going
to washington but i i'm the one that got the new job though
i wait wait you think it'll break yeah jump on the bridge
wait wait wait a minute can i oh let's get it throw it in
the water
okay where's the luggage wait where did it go oh it's right
here it's right here it's this grass creek what if there was
like a little troll under here yeah the troll dog where the
boys
okay i was wondering soft lock us back there right like you
see the luggage slowly drift along the river what see that
no there was a deer oh spooky ran past oh and this is a
two-hour game we're almost on we're almost on maybe probably
who knows oh fade black yeah loading
If there's like a foxy jump scare 9.58.
Oh, wait, it's not too bad.
It's another hour.
Did we make it?
Oh, am I holding my luggage?
I am still holding the luggage.
Yeah, we got this.
Keep going.
Alright.
Oh, there's a light.
I see the light.
The old house sat on the other side of the road.
Alright.
I'm not gonna look both ways.
I'm just gonna run.
There is a car heading over.
Wait, what if?
Oh.
I could get insurance right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Stay with us.
Clean beds, hot meals, no vacancy elsewhere.
Oh.
Wait, this place does look way bigger than...
Private property, no trespassing.
Oh, no.
No, we're customers.
That's true.
We're not trespassing, guys.
We deserve to be here.
All right.
Just because of the environment, I'm going to let you knock
first.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That and breakfast.
Oh, I got a text message, too.
Okay, yeah, I checked that.
Uh, due to return tomorrow.
Need more time.
Extend.
Oh, I can't extend.
Charlotte called ahead.
Such a sweet woman, isn't she?
Uh-huh.
You poor things.
Car giving you trouble on a night like this.
I know.
All right.
all right all right she doesn't seem racist so i can i'm
gonna come in are you too hungry yes yes we are i'm starving
okay we're so hungry what thank you you don't speak um we
just had a conversation about how you don't speak for both
of us marcus this is tessa tessa what a lovely name you're
going to feel right at home here my dear acknowledge you?
Yeah.
Um, hello?
I Is it you alone?
Why would you ask that?
Run this place by yourself.
Yeah.
No.
Could you imagine me here all alone?
Where are the other staff?
I've got a few hired hands.
Folks from the church also check in.
Oh.
How much from the church?
Do we owe you for the room?
Depends on how long you've been staying.
Only one night.
Oh my gosh.
For the night, it's night at five.
95 95 this is about inflation we'll square away payment in
the morning what the fuck yeah can we get a room could we
get to our room please that's like five dining prices that's
like a five-star hotel right there back in the 2000s it's
because she has a monopoly oh my gosh she's right remember
she has no vacancy elsewhere like yeah excuse me is there a
restroom It's in the back by the kitchen.
Oh, he just doesn't even look at me when she says that.
I know, she doesn't even look at me.
Oh, I really had to pee.
I had to wait for Mr. Oh.
Oh, you can't even come.
Bye.
I go pee now.
Oh, my God.
That's statue.
Wait, care.
Are you not allowed inside?
No, I can't go in.
No pee for you.
Oh, no.
Okay, also this area is actually pretty spooky.
There's like, there's a bunch of religious statues
everywhere.
Oh, have fun.
Yeah, there's a, there's, There's the Virgin Mary.
And then on the side, there's like this.
Yeah, no.
This room sucks.
That's fine.
I'm going to go sit down and play play.
Oh.
Why do I have to go to the bathroom?
Oh, hey.
There you go.
Oh, that's...
I'm just going to close that door while I pee.
Look at that, guys.
Hole in one.
I don't miss.
Oh.
Oh, I,
oops.
Hey, guys.
Oh.
Um.
Did you hear what they said, What?
What do you say?
I think they might be...
I think they might be cannibals.
Two hour and 34 minutes and 50 seconds.
It has been zero days since Cannibalism has been mentioned
on my channel.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Wait, no, I had a guy run out of the door and he was like,
if you, whatever you guys are doing in here, I want no part
of it.
I'll go ahead and put you in our majestic suite.
You talk about camels every day?
It's the process of my head.
Give you a deeper respect for this majestic house.
Why do you talk about this?
Anyway.
Anyway, so while I was peeing, they're like, they sure look
tasty and I'm like, what?
They might be dead.
Yeah, this guy, he came running down and he was just like,
he was like, you should be ashamed of yourself.
Whatever you guys are doing here.
I want no part of it and just ran out That's not good.
Let's go to our room, I guess.
Oh wait.
What's over here?
This is our Parsons study.
Oh, I thought she was bleeding.
Oh, yeah, that's the that's see this is what I mean.
Look at that creepy statue on the right.
Oh, that's scary.
Yeah
We got history older than anything my dears feel free to
browse the shells if you'd like a good read Alright.
Alright, so what was your last cannibalism conversation,
man?
I care to explain.
I don't know.
I'm sure somebody has time-stamped it, though.
I don't actually have the lights.
That thing scares me every time.
This place is old, and that includes the pipes.
The pipes?
Yep, and remember, this is $93.
Oh, don't drink the water.
Don't drink the water.
It's probably drugged.
Wait, did you drink the water?
no I did you want to drink the water did you call for the
shake she coughed she's patient zero are you drinking from
the what's going on I fade to black what's going on am I
still drinking oh okay I'm done it's like no click on it
okay I'll drink the water too it's like the longest fade to
black I was Like, what am I doing?
Like, it doesn't...
Like, am I dying?
Oh, this is the bathroom.
Oh.
You washed your hands, right?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, of course I did.
Oh, my God.
Do you still have your fucking auto-clicker on?
No, that was just...
That was all me.
No, yeah, all you.
I think we're going upstairs.
Get our suitcase.
all right suitcases here read thank you for choosing to stay
at old scratch temple's parsonage this house has stood in
service of the temple for generations and we take great
pride in its history I really like that even note about the
temple every tenant must sign it is the rule of the house
and a tradition we have kept since the earliest days thank
you for honoring our customs and the legacy of old scratch
temple gratitude gratuities who it is for bobby and henry
are appreciated miss julia all right let's go to our room is
this our room i thought someone was walking up the stairs at
night but never saw anyone what overall a pleasant stay
grateful for the shelter and the closeness not everywhere
will hold watch after dark you do may he bless you said
brother bless you evan and claire question woods.
Claire says the church made her uncomfortable.
I thought it was quaint and delightful.
We'll recommend you to friends.
Stayed the night before the meeting.
Everything is ready.
The morning star watches over you.
How many people have stayed here?
There's a lot of pages.
Heard the bell at 3
27 a.m.
No one else did.
That's how I know it's still listed.
Oh my god, there's so many pages.
There's so many pages.
I'm sure all these people were fine.
I'm sure.
I'm sure they're all okay now.
Come on.
Come on, Tessa.
We gotta go to our room.
I'm tired.
Me too.
I'm coming.
This is the bathroom.
I don't see any lights, though.
Love you, daddy.
Alright, let's shine the light.
I need to see what the sweet though.
Oh, yeah, but I don't know if there's any ghosts in the
bathroom No Okay, it was locked That's locked.
Oh Oh my god Oh,
oh, is this?
Oh, she's in there.
Wait, who's down here?
Yeah, I was gonna sit No one no one Oh, we can look through
the window.
Oh, we can Alright, let's go inside.
Alright, now I'm gonna talk to you.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
What was he doing here?
To a comfortable temperature.
So you shouldn't feel a chill tonight.
The staff put in extra effort this evening to prepare for
your arrival.
So I hope everyone needs your expectations.
Oh, and if you need anything at all, press zero on the
telephone.
Alright, zero on the telephone.
only okay okay that is we'll call if we need anything we'll
call if we need wait i can't even talk to her she doesn't
even give me an option to talk to her i'll leave you two to
it you know when both of us have options to do dialogue i
don't even have it i don't even have the option ourselves
tonight all right oh kitchen fight
each of you folks at old scratch temple like to make sure
people keep themselves pure oh it's that type of church oh
wait don't worry I can talk to her now keep it as okay yeah
yeah yeah well good then oh sorry do you mind if we get the
room key oh sweetie huh I'm afraid a house this old doesn't
have keys for What?
Whoa.
That's not even, that's.
Door locks itself.
I don't, what?
How do you get in then?
Oh, skeleton key.
We do charge $20 for the trip.
What?
So figured I'd move in the car.
Ask for the skeleton key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would like that.
God word, I can't give you the skeleton key.
What?
It unlocks every door in the house.
But is it $28?
Not that you two would go.
So like $28 per like, unlock yeah I think so if you get
locked out oh which means we just have to keep the door open
all the time well it locks itself so you would seem the out
it like in one okay maybe you're right oh do you want to
sign the guest wait before we go I want to watch TV don't
seem like the oh yeah I want to see kitchen night me too you
just close the door on her
We were both super exhausted.
I saw these people came here to help my restaurant out, not
make fun of it.
They told me to brush my teeth.
Such a shame.
Are you gonna go sign the guest book?
No, I'm gonna watch TV.
Wow.
Leslie, wake up!
Dear Lord!
Yeah, Leslie!
What the hell?
Leslie, take your hand off the flag.
It's on fire.
Oh my god, Leslie.
No!
Okay, I'll go.
I'll go.
Wait, wait, wait.
You're missing a good part.
Wait, you're gonna miss a good part.
Wait, that's that's Gordon.
That's Morgan.
Hormsey.
It's over.
I think...
I think I need a bath.
I feel disgusting.
The fish has taken over the factory?
What's this?
Yeah, after, oh, I got a message from dad.
Oh, a sleep son started to get the car.
No dice on getting the car fixed today.
Bill's wife set us up at bed and breakfast.
He's going to fix the car in the morning.
We just got here.
Oh, shit.
This looks sick.
Are you having a bath?
Honda!
Yo, we gotta get this car!
with 800 horsepower oh my god there's some roy and no bitch
show oh my god my girlfriend's texting me right now but but
i'll text her back after this show she knows she she knows
it's my time she she knows this is dookie dad welcome back
to the rory no bitch show for those just tuning in episode
has been a wild one with no signs of slowing down let's
introduce our next guest
oh my god is he gonna walk down there oh my god he fell down
the stairs oh my god he me mori elijah is here because 10
days ago his son elijah jr requested a dna test i see the
father elijah could be his real dad elijah how did this make
you feel oh my god honestly mori it hurt my ding-dong
feelings is what it did i've spent years raising elijah jr
and this seems like it came clear out of my field well we'll
be getting answers soon enough but let's see what elijah jr
had to say about the situation what up my name is ej they
used to call me elijah jr but i don't claim that name just
because i hate my dad elijah is a loser what kind of grown
man walks around with light up shoes this man bought
superhero bed sheets for himself for himself
whack-ass in my mama's house every year i don't get why he's
acting this way wow yeah they sure are anyway let's not wait
any longer let's bring out ej
yeah yeah whatever shut up shut up Whatever.
EJ.
Thanks for being here today.
Now we heard your explanation, but there has to be a reason
beyond that for not wanting Elijah to be your dad.
Why doesn't he want to be his dad?
He can provide for him.
You know who my friend's dad is?
Rodney Iconic.
Oh no!
I'm sorry.
Who?
Rodney Iconic.
He's a popular rapper, actor.
He thinks his dad is a rapper.
Oh,
she needed it out.
What kind of 34 year old money?
Is this true?
Yes, Rory.
What he's not sharing is that.
He's my bully.
Pay up, bitch.
Okay, that's it.
I've heard enough.
We're gonna get to the bottom of this here and now.
I'm gonna go get your towels.
I have a watch TV.
Okay, EJ.
You are his son.
Oh my god, he's his son!
Yay!
Oh my god!
I told you he was my son.
I knew it!
Wait a minute, they're not results.
That's just a photo of me.
Actually, son, that's a picture of me when I was your age.
Back then, I was all that and a bag of chips, as we said.
Wait, so you used to look like that, and now you look like
this.
Does that mean?
Yeah, it'll happen to you, too, son.
Ah!
When we return, we're going to meet Brittany, who wants to
confront her brother, who constantly misusing the word a
few.
We'll be back after these short messages.
Elijah.
Elijah, stop dancing.
Stop it.
Then how are you texting?
I'm not thriving.
What does that mean?
killer with this sandwich.
I want out of the bathroom.
A pickle leprechaun!
I think it's time to figure out how to...
I want to get rid of the iron leprechaun.
Boy oh golly oh boy, I thought you'd never ask.
Introducing Leprechaun's Pickle with the all new pickle
leprechaun!
The sour little crunch makes your pickles twice as crunchy,
all the more tasty, and just as desirable.
Only at your local pigliest pickle store within the pickle
aisle.
The best part is they're cheap.
Less than the cost of a bite.
What's shaking, baby?
Oh boy.
I couldn't help myself.
The aura, the smell.
I could taste it through the glass.
Tastes it through the glass.
Yeah, right.
I ain't buying that.
Don't believe it.
Here, have a snack.
Looks a choice then holy leprechaun it's real it's crispy
crunchy sour knuckle-feeling leprea fruit pickled see here
i'm a second bite give me give me give me give me give me oh
man oh are these so Crunchy!
I can't hold back!
I must eat more!
Get out of my mind.
Oh,
uh-oh.
I don't know what to do with mine.
I know what to say.
The pickles and towels.
Get yours now!
Oh, there we go.
That was not in the game.
That was me.
For the first time in the history of the show, an ordinary
farmer has fallen in love with an alien.
And he has 24 hours.
With an alien?
And obtain an intergalactic K1 visa.
Welcome to the show.
90 Acre Fiancé.
90 Acre Fiancé?
Not much, but it's on its way.
my name is Earl do not fuck the chicken I signed up for the
program because I fell in love across the galaxy we met when
she tried to kidnap my cow but she asked politely and I
appreciated her manners I knew she was the one when she left
proof of her love behind in the cornfield she flew away
besides I heard she has access to a market of 12 billion
consumers oh my god there's the ship no problem i'm saturday
off alienated at first sight alienated at first sight triple
smoke backyard mega monkey excellent what's your favorite
song open the door i am going to kill you i'm going to
murder you you will never be happy you will never live a
happy life you will grow old and sad but i'll have 90.
90 Acres Fiancé
You could have watched the CV with me You could have done a
watch along with me That's on you You just had to take a
bath You just had to take a bath I Wouldn't have watched my
favorite show if I'm fine.
I'll grab the towel.
Okay, but you got it.
You got to tell me what happens after.
Okay, when I grab the towels, you got to tell me what
happens later.
Oh, he's dead.
You know we don't have a show now where no one's going to
pay you.
He killed the cameraman.
You're missing it out.
You're missing out on the show.
I'm gonna grab the towels!
Why do I always- wait, I already unlocked it.
Wait, what?
There's a rat in this sandwich.
Okay, unlock?
Um...
Mint?
Um Sometimes I just think people don't know a good thing
when they see it, you know, they just like to complain Um
You got right, honey Yes Oh Oh Oh,
I had to call for towels Hi, um, sorry to bother you My, uh,
girlfriend's in the bathroom I had Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I don't know you know this, but I just needed to call I
just needed to call for towels.
Everyone will know you're on that television.
Dear, I hate to wait them for anything short of an
emergency.
Right, I understand, but and a missing towel wouldn't
qualify, I'm afraid.
we wait and all is starting to sing but my girlfriend's
already yeah if it's something you need right now you'll
have to help yourself i'd help myself okay for the parsonage
and church is kept in the basement wait i have to go get it
why am i doing all the spooky stuff if you head out through
the back door to the church why won't you do the spooky
stuff this is karma for me watching my favorite show just
because i wanted me time
Well, then, if you'll excuse me, it's getting harder.
Look, I have to go to the basement, Mint.
Mint.
I'm going to go to the basement now.
I'll be back in five minutes.
Boo.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
I got to go downstairs to grab towels.
I'll be right back.
Right now?
She said everyone's asleep.
It's the only option.
You said?
Do you think Min is okay in the bath?
Oh, she went to get dinner.
I'll leave a TV on for her.
Don't worry, I booze!
I left the TV on for you!
So you guys can listen to the TV!
I'm so... I'm a nice person.
I should have left the door...
This is actually karma.
There we go.
I gotta go to the creepy basement now.
Yeah.
I'm a good person.
I look the TV on for the eyeballs.
So they have like something to hear.
Where is the basement?
Is it this way?
Oh, I forgot to bring the flashlight.
Oh, it'll be fine, right?
What?
Oh, I hear a TV from above.
Is it here?
Oh, is it here?
Where the fuck is the basement?
Oh.
No, that's the outside.
Uh.
I don't know where the basement is.
You would think it's like here.
Oh, it was outside.
okay why did i i have to go pee and i have to go to the
basement like i get all the spooky shit i deserve tv time
okay this sucks she i forgot to bring the flashlight okay
the fuck is oh there's the creepy church of course the
creepy church has the red light on
oh no all right i'm gonna go back up Wait, can she leave the
room or no?
Wait, if I have the door closed.
Can she leave now or no?
Or, like, is it trapped in the...
Is it trapped in my room?
Oh, my God.
Alright, we're gonna try and...
We're gonna feel the walls.
Alright.
It's fine.
I won't need the flashlight.
I'll just hug the wall until I hit the basement.
Jesus.
the wall until I feel basement where could it be the
one that has to go to the creepy and think it's a creepy
basement oh it's at the church oh that church basement all
right this way oh this is a how do I get to the church wait
I can't get off the pathway, though.
Yeah, let her know I'm heading.
Oh, there it is.
God, it's so dark.
If only... Oh, there's a cemetery behind the bed and
breakfast?
Okay.
There's a lot of disclaimers that we didn't read about this
church.
Alright.
Church to storm the blankets.
I'm at it.
I left the TV on for you.
Oh, it is pretty dark.
Wait.
By the way, that's the TV.
By the way, you took the only flashlight So, I can't see
shit.
It's very dark.
I'm thinking I'm going to get murdered in this church.
Boo.
I hope I die here.
So, you'll never...
Get your towel.
And you stuck in the bathroom.
Oh, what?
I'm coming back to grab a flashlight.
I'm coming back.
I need the flashlight.
I can't progress.
I don't, oh my god.
never mind game said no there's the basement okay it is
inside I
think this was karma
yes okay that's a door right okay there is a basement light
always had a fear oh my god now it gives me a fucking
flashlight okay so that's where all the towels oh there's
the towels oh what's that hello hello who's there oh wait oh
my god
seems more paranormal rather than something scary on a
tangible level i didn't know what to do Please come to
church.
Unlock door.
I picked this.
I texted this at all first.
I did it before.
Now can you read this?
Bruh.
Maybe there's...
Anything else here?
Okay.
What the fuck?
They have a jackhammer here.
Why is this my job?
I actually got chills.
I kind of got...
Oh, and then Mint gets to sit on her ass at the hotel room.
I have to go to the creepy basement.
Yeah, yeah, this is karma.
Oh, for some talent.
Oh, she's calling Julia.
Why are you calling Julia?
Okay,
I have no network now.
I have no network.
I swear to God, she bet, I swear to God.
I hope someone jumps over into a room and goes, ooga, booga,
booga.
Of course, I get this.
I couldn't believe what the actual fuck I was seeing.
I couldn't believe I didn't.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I can hear a fucking calling, Julia.
Someone already visited her.
Oh, oh.
Hello.
Was it cow?
Was that John cow?
Anybody there?
Oh, yeah.
Did she let the coach into her room?
I fucking knew it.
Yeah, for her coaching sessions.
Men is hanging out with another...
I left for five seconds.
For five seconds.
And then she lets another man into the room.
Yeah, that was a coffin.
they're clicking cows together oh all right
easy come easy go oh is that the car what the fuck where the
fuck oh anybody there oh yes let me go yell it out here in
this creepy mine shaft with Oh, of course it opens inward Oh
There's lots of mosquitoes stop calling the phone.
Okay, we're oh my god
See this is why I would die first of course they send me in
first for everything Of course, oh my god got all my
messages i'm going to sleep hello get on cow up on cow i had
no reception there are coffins right here the tv above me
oh okay
the hell are you doing down there what was i doing down
there maybe fix your doors before blaming me i was stuck
getting the towels had to make my way out okay
and this is why this is exactly why i didn't i went watch tv
for the first 20 minutes This is exactly why I have to do
this.
I needed my TV time
All right, so I'm grooving my brain insisted not to tell
Tessa everything I got Jump scared.
You're one out of there immediately
For your stupid towels I
A man.
Who do I get to play as Leon?
Open the door.
I got your towel.
Open the fucking door.
Do you want your towels or not?
Get over here.
I got your stupid towel.
I went into the creepy-ass basement.
locked in the church.
Get the door open.
I know you let another man in.
It was Harry.
Who's Harry?
Huh?
I found him.
He was supposed to come give me towels.
Are you okay?
So what the hell?
This was so boring for me.
I would gladly swap places with you i had to go to the
creepy ass church go to the basement for your and i got
locked out so he's laughing about it find the towels yeah
let me put them in the bathroom all right i got you your
towels how was it boy you get to watch tv was that show not
entertaining i had a fun time nah what do you mean where do
i put the towels where do i put the towels
probably here am I?
No where the fuck do I put the towel here maybe oh maybe oh
maybe up here oh no that's we can lock it yeah there was a
guy standing down there oh I think I was watching him
waiting for you to jump oh wait in here in here okay yeah
boo boo boo a guy came up here while you were gone who came
up who came out yeah i don't know one of the workers or
something and he just that was not that's not creepy why are
we coughing just like the lady oh what of course not good it
was weird boo miss julia said that everyone was asleep
that's not true i got jump scared that's not true oh i put
another towel down didn't say anything everybody kept
hanging up the phone for me oh yeah i could see it was like
calling miss julia i saw you try to call her like five times
what is that not it i put do you have to click it click the
towel i found it what are you doing putting on my towel wait
have i not been naked no you are not naked no see that's so
weird i was like what what are we supposed to do I'm
coughing just like the lady I'm sick in the head I'm sick in
the head all right we got the towel just sniffed are we both
sick I think so we drank the way we have to sleep we have to
sleep now oh you don't even take a bag but I was got you a
towel so you're not even gonna fucking you're not even gonna
you're not even gonna take a bath I'm like this I'm sleeping
do you know my trauma No, no, no, no, no.
Go sleep.
Oh my god.
Epilepsy warning.
Someone call the police.
She's trying to make me epileptic.
Go fuck.
Fucking go to sleep.
You're walking.
Yeah.
I'm progressing.
I was locked out.
Just like you are.
No.
Yes.
I was locked in that damn bathroom for like I was trying to
get you not so I did I literally told you I literally told
you I had a cutscene with Miss Julia.
I Don't believe you.
I had a cutscene with Miss Julia.
It was not my fault.
I'm going to sleep.
I want to sleep All right, Marcus you liar I don't think
we're supposed to go to sleep.
I don't what are we supposed to do?
Are you supposed to just go in the bathroom and take a bath?
Okay, I'll close the door.
I'll go close What?
What?
We're- Don't turn that on.
Go- Go take your bath.
I'll close the door.
Wait, am I fine?
I was in the bath.
What am I doing?
Are you taking a bath right now?
We gotta go sign the guest book.
Oh my god.
For- Oh my god.
The fucking guest book.
All right.
Go and lock the door.
Ladies first.
Wait, I'm stuck.
I can't actually- Wait, I'm stuck.
Okay, okay, lady.
Okay.
pocket oh my god oh my god okay all right come on okay wait
i can't oh you are oh now you have to do it i realized i
shouldn't have left the door open okay okay goodbye now i'm
gonna watch tv when we return we're gonna meet brittany who
wants to confront her brother who constantly
short messages yeah I get to watch my show let's see oh my
god it's the pickle ad wait do you know what would be killer
with this sandwich a pickle leprechaun but what in the world
is Yeah, well it's a pickle leprechaun.
Oh my god.
With the all new pickle leprechaun.
The sour little friend who makes your pickles twice as
crunchy, all the more tasty and just as desirable.
I'm glad that she has to go down now too.
We both suffer together.
The best part is their cheese.
Cheap.
Okay, look at him go.
You know what that show reminds me of?
I think it's the same animator.
It's the one that, that's the squid game where they start
twerking.
I'm pretty sure it's literally the same animator that I
recognize.
I recognize the motion.
Yeah.
Holy leprechaun, it's real.
Look at him go.
Crunchy, sour, knuckle-feeling, leopard-proof pickles.
See?
I'm a second boy My guys go over to ocean and pick it is I'm
pretty sure the same animator Like the motion and everything
What's shaking baby
What's shaking, baby?
Let's get ours now!
It's Pickers!
What is she?
Oh my god, 90 acres of fiancé.
This is my favorite show.
And he has 24 hours to convince her and her family and
obtain an intergalactic K-1 visa.
Welcome to the show.
90-acre fiancé.
Right.
Yeah, it's not much, but it's honest work.
My name is Earl.
I have a corn farm and an open heart.
I signed up for the program because I fell in love across
the galaxy.
We met when she tried to kidnap my cow, but she asked
politely.
Well, he's writing her five things.
I knew she was the one when she left proof of her love
behind in the cornfield.
She flew away.
Besides, I heard she has access to a market of 12 billion
consumers who only eat corn.
no problem i'm saturday off alienated at first sight what's
your favorite song it's simple triple smoke backyard i
wonder i wonder if she'll get paranoid with that your
favorite song well okay let's get back to earl earl would
you like to have children in the future wait i didn't get at
least two at most as many as i could fit it in my pickup
truck without oh no not chicken we had too many chickens
anyway besides it was super cute yeah it's time to meet the
bride's parents mom on the left and dad on the right oh okay
now that i see the context of this we'll cut that out come
closer with the camera i want a close-up of their faces
give her permission hey will you send it to me later that
was incredible that was pretty lame you know we don't have a
show now and no one's going to me why hello hello hello
all right episode of kitchen fright we fly over to
Cincinnati Ohio we're old couple has begun to notice that
where did the cow go all right guys don't worry the cow's
back baby every health code in the book i don't say can i
afford another there's a rat in this you know it's crazy the
the auto clicker um the auto clicker was too good to be it
was too good i got spoiled by it magic clicking for yourself
you're feeding people rats this is crazy matt
think people don't know a good thing when they see it you
know they just like to complain and complain and complain
ain't that right honey i'm getting water poor she coming
from these sinks have you checked your plumbing yet yes i
did i fixed it myself this looks like you can't be washing
dishes here washing dishes why would we do that because you
would be serving people food on place that I feel man are
you not okay I saw sleep oh man god yeah she did yeah what
the hell is wrong with you there is nothing wrong with it
people do not need to know everyone will know you're on
television good she got jump scared good we take turns we
fucking take turns
Reverse karma.
These people came here to help my restaurant out, not make
fun of it.
Such a shame.
Leslie, where's the order for table three?
Yeah, equal rights for equal frights.
Leslie, wake up.
Dear Lord, this kitchen is absolute shit.
What the hell?
Leslie, take your hand off the plate.
Oh, that's true.
Can I do that?
Is that a bottle of tequila?
Don, I thought you were done with the drink.
Food.
That concludes our episode of Kitchen Frights.
Tune in next time when Sheldon Ramsey's visits a local fish
factory in Houston, Texas, where the fish have taken over
the factory.
Shh.
Oh my god.
You didn't lock the door?
Doki.
Are you trying to jump scare me?
hello
boo oh you were gone a while miss julia stopped me
downstairs
yeah i pulled yeah but i pulled it through okay i finished
the job i love to say where was he What did he look like?
What did he look like?
He just, he looked like a man.
Yeah.
I stood there and covered for you, and I don't even know
what I'm covering for.
What are we, what are we arguing about?
Why did you go into the basement, huh?
She got mad at me.
Oh.
This one was connected to the church basement.
I got locked in there and ended up coming back through the
wrong side.
A tunnel?
Yeah, it was like filled with coffins and stuff.
This house.
But why?
I don't know.
I didn't build it.
It's an old building.
Tessa finally said she thinks something's weird going on Now
she thinks something's weird.
Yeah, yeah after everything.
That's fucking weird And what's also weird is you didn't
think to tell me any of this I just didn't want to freak you
out.
Yeah for no reason that's like just doing that what Stop
making decisions for the of us are you serious i'm just
trying to protect you boo what did you want me to do test
come back up here and tell you about a secret what do you
think you're a ghost you're trying to steal my stick with no
car you've already been on the edge for no reason this whole
time maybe stop reading into things and just let me yeah let
me handle it i'm the man of the house that's right okay yeah
sure you handle it it's right you handle it i'm just gonna
watch tv from now on You want me to try a TV?
Mm-hmm.
All right, we can go watch TV while we sleep.
Also, why is the TV facing that side?
You would think it'd be on over here in the center.
You know?
There's no room for it there.
And reposition the beds.
Well, of course you want me closest to the door, you know?
Of course.
News you lose.
Okay.
All right.
I love you.
Yeah.
Good night, boo.
it back this guy has no worries ever you didn't even say i
love you back you just oh all right i see how it is i i see
wait what the fuck mint Mint?
Mint?
Are you getting creepy visions too?
Are you also getting creepy visions?
What's going on?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm slowly walking towards the light.
Come to the light.
Oh.
oh no follow i'm gonna follow your voice i'm at a gas
station do you hear me
the fuck is this game what did mint make me play like the
first hour i was playing cow clicker and now i'm at oh oh
come as oh now oh all right the map the game was like Please
walk over there.
I'm walking over there now.
Alright.
I swear to God, I'm gonna get another jump scare.
It's like that.
It's like that game where...
Wait, that video of the car video where you follow the car
and then the car disappears and then the fucking zombie pops
out and goes Booga Booga Booga!
It is how it feels right now.
Did you see it?
Yeah.
Hey, did you also get a creepy dream?
Oh, oh, of course.
Only I wake up.
Of course.
A fucking chorus.
Wake up, boo.
Wait.
What?
Man?
Okay.
Oh!
I need to tell you something.
Boo!
Open the door!
He's coming.
Marcus was not a light sleeper.
Open up!
Open!
What am I supposed to do?
I tried opening, but...
We need to go.
Right now.
What?
Get out.
Go, go, go.
We have.
He left.
We have to go.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
How did you die?
She stabbed me!
Okay, okay, okay, we gotta go.
We... I think we got red.
Red, red, red.
okay which way do we go wait where do you have to lay okay
okay we need to go we need to go we need let's try the door
by the water oh yeah yeah yeah yeah kitchen right kitchen oh
yeah yeah go Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Kitchen by the kitchen.
Oh my god, I don't have the flashlight, so it's like so
disorienting.
Oh my god.
Where do we go?
Ah!
You got stuck!
We have to go to the tunnels!
Wait, where's the tunnels?
I don't...
The tunnels!
I remember how to get to the tunnels.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I got...
Go, go, go.
I got a lot.
I the poor door pushed me the doors pushed me the tunnels
okay we go I know where it is The tunnels okay, I'm gonna
follow you.
Follow me follow me
It's locked.
It's locked ah we go
Okay, I might have did I cool up did I wait wait is there an
extra flashlight here Get out go.
No, okay.
So I went the wrong door should be there should be I want we
come in here come in here Let's see if we can find the other
flashlight.
Nah, it's fine.
No, there's no other flashlight.
Just you only have the only flashlight.
Do you want it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
All right.
I know where to go.
All right, let's go.
I'm following you.
All right, follow me.
Oh, my God.
I hate that it does that.
All right, it's the store.
It's the store.
It's not the store.
Oh, my God.
No, it's not.
It's not the store.
We go to the church.
We go right.
Follow me, follow me, follow me, follow me, follow me.
We're going to the church, we're going to the church.
Follow me.
Why are we going to the church?
I don't know.
It's the other way.
Churches.
Oh, it's not the church.
It's not the church.
Oh.
Okay.
It's not the church.
Oh, I have to light now.
this
What if we go to the basement?
What if we go to basement?
What?
Get out.
Go, go, go.
Oh, I remember where it is.
I went to the wrong door.
I remember I chose the wrong door.
I chose I remember the actual door.
I know I know where it is.
I know where it is for real this time.
It's here.
The basement, the basement.
Oh my god, did you just shut the door?
Wait, it's locked.
This section took my friend 20 minutes, oh god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
There are coffins, the coffins.
I don't, it's the coffins.
There's coffins in the basement.
We need to go, right now.
Go, go, go, go.
We need to go.
We gotta go hide in the coffins.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
The basement!
That's what the coffins mean!
Okay.
Here, here!
There you go.
I might have said, there we go.
I'm...
Oh.
do you have the flashlight no you had the flashlight I might
have thrown the flashlight when I got in the coffin okay
okay this time this time we got it we got it this time
they came this way
we're okay
he always got his fucking cat
do we ride all right uh where do we go do we i think we go
the same way that we came from right and then because they
went the opposite way the thing is we don't have our
flashlight anymore.
Oh.
Which way did you go?
Is it chasing?
No!
Split up, gang!
To the card!
I went to the...
Oh my god.
I went to the church.
Get out.
Go, go, go.
Oh, I want to repent for my sins.
Oh my God, why did it put us all the way back here?
Oh my God.
I wanted to go to the church.
I thought the church was the answer.
Who's they came this way?
Closing around down here.
Scott.
I love you, Scott.
I'm playing cows.
Get out of the fucking coffin.
I tried texting you, but I said no signal.
Oh, no signal.
Yeah, yeah, that was me when I was in the basement.
Okay, this time, go to the front door.
Yeah, yeah, okay, I'll follow you this time.
That's what you should have done the first.
I got scared.
Okay, go, go.
I wish we had a flashlight, though.
It's actually hard to see.
I know, what happened to our flashlight?
I don't know.
Are you there?
I'm behind you.
Okay.
We're running.
Is this it?
Oh, yeah.
It's that scary.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's our car?
I don't know where to go from here.
woods again.
Where are you?
I can't see you!
Oh, we did it.
Did we do it?
Oh.
What's going on?
Why is it?
Oh, that's where our car is.
Yeah.
It's our bed and the bill.
Oh.
What's that?
So what's his name?
What do we do?
The guy, the guy that was supposed to fix our car is there.
He might kill us.
I think he's got a guy.
He has a gun.
He's a gun.
We could take their car.
Yeah, we could take their car.
What's the news?
This is Get Out.
This is the movie.
You learned me in here.
It's just me in here.
You lured me in here.
It's just like the movie.
I'm going to be in here.
My brain's going to be someone else's body.
I just wanted some parry at the old bread bed and bread and
back you gotta swap my brain oh wait if we crouch what if we
walk and crouch walk I think you're gonna kill us let's just
try I said I'm coming you're so stupid you That was not it.
That was not it.
You are so stupid.
You are...
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to listen to the dialogue.
How was I supposed to know?
I'm pretty sure.
He was like, Billy boy.
It's fine.
We're back here.
All right.
We're back to listening to the dialogue.
Billy boy.
Where is he?
He's like walking out.
Yeah, I see him.
Wait, I don't see him.
Wait, did he spawn?
Because he killed you?
I see.
Do you see him?
No, where is he?
Wait, do you see him?
Wait, we can skip the dial.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's, I'm skipping.
Okay, we skip?
Yeah.
Wait.
Is he talking?
Yeah, yeah.
Something about the first time?
It'll be the last time.
Yeah, yeah.
What do we do?
He's looking.
Is he coming out here?
He should be very quiet.
Oh, is he looking at us?
He's looking for us, yeah.
Oh, look, he's turning around.
Should we go?
Yeah, I think so.
You first.
Me first!
Why?
Yes, you first.
Oh.
Wait, what if he just like...
I don't think so.
Which way, which, where, do we take our car?
But it doesn't move.
I think we take their car, remember?
Which one is theirs?
The truck?
I think when he turns around, the music goes, weeem.
I think when we turns around, we go.
Yes, yes, he's not looking.
Yeah, yeah, let's go.
All right.
Do we get in our car?
Oh
Maybe maybe maybe it's time to skip the dialogue We both
went the same door We won't both what it I was in front of
you you go to the front
Where are you?
Oh Wait, is he Are they talking?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god.
He's right in front of us.
Wait, what's happening?
He's glitched.
Do you see that?
I see the car.
It's a truck over there.
Do you see it?
I see the car.
Oh, I said I'm coming.
Oh, okay.
You skipped it?
Okay, good.
Wait, isn't that the guy that owns the gas station?
No, no.
That's the different guy.
I'm pretty sure.
No, I'm pretty sure the guy that is what the question is.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Why?
Don't you own the gas station?
Ah, okay, okay, I'm ready.
Wait, not yet.
Are we trying for his car?
I think we're trying for hours.
I'm pretty sure we- are we?
Okay, let's try.
Yeah, I'm going for our car.
I'm getting in the driver's seat.
Oh, sorry.
Okay!
Alright!
Okay, I'm
done!
Of course he opens my passenger!
It's fine!
We didn't know that we didn't know the trailer!
Now we know we have to get rid of the trailer!
But our couch!
Our couch!
My Samsung friend!
You drive then, you drive!
do the you do the trailer and i get in the car no why do i
have to do the trailer because you you haunt you haunt the
car you
oh i said i'm coming okay first time that won't be the way
okay okay where is he oh he's he's leaving the porch
okay oh not yet
okay how do i do this just click on it
oh go go go oh oh bob he's driving
Turn on the radio.
Oh my god.
What do we do?
We're getting out of here!
Oh my god.
I might have accidentally hit the tree.
No, I noticed.
I noticed.
I'm just...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Do we get our car?
Oh my god.
Are you skip the dialogue again?
I think you have to just drive and ignore him.
Yeah.
okay okay all right your turn your turn to drive oh my god
we take turns until it works
you get the trailer then all right need first time yeah two
hour game oh my gosh only two miles an hour it still hits
the tree was gonna be so fast
not yet
Okay.
Go.
Why is the radio on?
Because I turned it on.
I can get in.
Alright.
How do I- Oh!
Why did I do this?
Woo!
He's right behind us!
I'm gonna text my dad.
Oh my god.
I'm going to be on my phone.
I'm playing.
I'm going to.
We're getting faster.
Like when you're hitting on the road.
I think it's the road.
Don't hit that tree.
Oh, it's not.
Is he on us?
Is he behind us?
We made it.
We barely made it back to the main road before the car gave
out again.
We were scared that those people were going to follow us.
We called the cops and we were rescued to the station.
Two officers went back to the area immediately.
We didn't find anything criminal.
That's all we heard back in the morning.
At first, it drove me insane.
But Tesla said it was not worth pressing on.
As nobody called us crazy.
The sheriff actually seemed to kind of believe us, which
mission managed to creep her out even more.
As far as I know, those monsters are still out there in the
world.
Whichever they wanted, it wasn't just money.
As I wrote this story, I'm well aware of the stupid choices
I made along the way.
I'm just so thankful we're both... It's like that bricks
thing, right?
church.
Oh, thank God.
I don't know how she dealt with that.
I can't hear you.
What did you do?
Oh, my God.
Dude.
I was like, how are she still reading?
How, you know, the moment you've been?
it said you were still reading you were still reading no it
said you were still reading i was i was looking at that text
me too me too me too i was looking at that text i was
looking at it first i promise you know i feel like if we
didn't get distracted with the cows uh we could finish we
could finish this game in an hour not gonna lie let's see i
think so too also if somebody had gone and gotten me towels
when they should have i did then I was trapped in the base.
No, I was trapped in the basement.
No, I don't think so.
I didn't get to- I was trapped in the basement.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
Anyway, thanks for playing with me.
Thank you for playing my game.
No problem.
That was fun.
That was silly.
We missed the steps of the game bugged at the end.
Apparently there was like a step that we missed.
And that's why it bugged out.
Oh, wait, but we got the trailer, no?
Yeah, yeah, but apparently there was an extra step, so we
weren't not supposed to, like...
I just brute force it.
That's why the car stalled for so long.
Wait, what was the step, guys?
What was the step?
What?
Like, you were supposed to...
You were supposed to...
Oh, no, I did.
I unhooked it.
I did unhooked it.
yeah hold on i'm gonna click out of the if i'm not lagging
there we go i did there was never a hand break there was
never a break on it that that doesn't matter we did it till
you're supposed to you're supposed to hide in the trip oh
what they're supposed to hide yeah i guess that's what
oh yeah it's fine i guess it would have been like we hide
the trailer and he walks away and then we unhook it and then
we drive off but we were remember at the very beginning yeah
yeah it was like you hide in the trailer yeah that was that
achievement there but we we did that in the very beginning
but like we it was so much like there was enough time to oh
apparently we're supposed to push the Yep, you pushed it for
us.
Yeah, and then in the end, we let him push it for us.
We're just like...
I guess that's why it's like...
Mwah!
We're so like...
Oh my god.
We're so good at this game.
We're too good at it.
We're too good.
They have another fear...
Like, you play the other fears to fathom, right?
Uh, yeah, yeah, I've played all of them.
Oh, you play all!
Hey, they should make another multiplayer one.
Yeah.
They should.
He said he didn't want to.
Oh, what?
Come on.
That was good cut.
That was fun.
It was fun though.
It was fun with two people.
Yeah.
You should play the other ones.
No, that's fine.
I will, I'll like join you on screen.
You all join me?
Okay.
All right.
It'll be like multiplayer.
Yeah, it's just be like multiplayer.
Wait, but you already played it so you know how it goes
though.
Yeah, I know.
I do have to go though Yeah, you're like a little Yeah,
we're like It's okay It's gonna be Wait, you missed a
meeting You Yeah Wait, how'd you know?
So in my chat told Rice said You missed a meeting for this
Well, to be fair Did you tell them It was because you were
playing Cow Clicker?
Actually, I forgot about my meeting Was it like a Was it
like a Densetsu meeting?
Yeah I forgot about it I don't understand.
You know, don't understand.
But also, I don't think I would have made it.
I think I would have been too busy.
Oh, that's true because of your packing and stuff.
You know, you got the experience, you know?
You warmed up in this game.
Wait, what time is it?
It's like midnight for you.
Oh, my God.
It's like...
It's all over for me.
It's like midnight for you.
Hey, you warmed up, though.
warmed up what you warmed up for packing because we packed
you know we packed in the beginning of the game so you're
practically warmed up you know how to tetris things better
now oh wait oh my my youtube is needing wait close clicker
clarity this was fun i'm gonna go next time when another
fear comes out another you play a fear hit us up well we'll
submit a story we should write we should write us we'll
submit our own story we gotta write a story we could be the
next we could be the next uh next duo on a road trip yeah
we'll even voice act for free devs hit us up we'll do it for
free put us next stream we write a story that submits to
fears of fathom and we're like this is a true story that
happened to us it's like we were playing fears to fathom and
then this happened yeah it's a game of in the game when the
paranormal activities happen okay well actually i gotta go
okay okay yeah yeah go back go back ggs thank you for
inviting me man thanks don't forget to me back on discord to
normal oh yeah yeah i'll do it right now yeah me too okay
all right i'll do yeah i got you okay all right yay all
right good luck in packing thanks bye bye bye bye bye that
was a fun game legitimately i really do think that if we
didn't get distracted with packing and also i was trying to
figure out the tetris Our, our, our, um, the, the, the
luggage and everything, and also we didn't get distracted by
CalClicker.
I'm pretty sure we could have finished this game within the
hour.
I'm pretty sure.
And yeah.
Oh my god, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Now, thank you so much.
I hope you enjoyed the stream.
Um, I had a lot of fun.
Huge shout out to Mint inviting me uh for this game it was
really fun I had a great time we found out that we're both
bad at driving in game though in game I will she is a good
driver in real life guys I am still alive
uh I'm gonna call it here but yeah no I really I'm so sorry
I had to push the stream for 30 minutes I was so fucked up I
literally woke up from my nap because the jetlight was
hitting me so hard And I messaged her, and I was like, I
need 30 more minutes.
And then she was like, wait, what was this?
She was like, if you give in to jet lag, it'll only get
worse.
And I literally napped an extra 20 minutes.
I didn't tell her that.
I was like, she was like, it's going to get worse if you
give in.
And I was like, don't worry.
And then I fell back asleep.
and i'm too weak i'm so weak and terrible thank you for the
10 gift and just thank you thank you i was so dead i really
needed that extra 20 minutes i
but thank you guys i had a lot of fun with men i hope you
guys had a lot of fun as well on stream um i'm gonna call it
here because like i said tomorrow we're going to be
streaming i know tweet about it, but I want to finish the
rest of the watch along.
It will be on Twitch, though, so feel free to check me out
on Twitch for tomorrow.
We're going to have it at 5.
5 p.m.
PSD.
I'll tweet about it as well.
So tomorrow, 5 p.m.
PSD.
We'll finish the rest of the watch along stuff.
And then because on Friday, we're going to have two streams
on Friday, which would be the James Bond stream and also the
collab.
So the collab is going to be like at 11.
So You're going to have that.
Easy.
Thank you for the 20 gifted ships.
Thank you.
And by collab, I mean 11 p.m.
on Friday.
I think that was the time.
I've got to double check.
Let me double.
Actually, I can double check right now.
Yeah, it's at 11 p.m.
on Friday.
For me, I'm the Iron Mouse and Rind.
So that's why I'm going to have to book it here.
I'm going to check out here, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
Thank you for all the gifted ships.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, everybody, for the support.
I'm glad you guys all had super fun watching.
Always had a really great time streaming with Mint.
It just feels like a hangout session.
Like it just comes naturally for us.
Even if we haven't collab in a while, it's just riding a
bike.
It just comes back to us.
When we were both really busy, but whenever we hang out
again, it just, it's just natural.
It's like riding a bike.
it's like we it's like we never left yeah as always
everybody say hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stood up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye yeah we like our our brain cells our
half of brain cell merges together whenever we collab to
form one big brain cell uh Oh, yeah, next thing, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's always such a fun time when the two of you are
together.
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa earlier.
Thank you.
All right, bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.